Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
Oh my god.
Okay, I fucked up a little bit because...
So, for those who don't know, I do have the early access...
I actually... Okay, so I fucked up several things.
So, I didn't realize that I actually have the early access copy.
So, I could've been...
I could play this game since this morning.
Because I was like, alright, gotta put my game releases on launch.
So, that's why I put it at 9 because I was like...
I didn't realize I had the early access game.
But I already made my schedule too.
I already made my schedule, so I was just like, okay, well...
I'm not gonna push this stream earlier.
Because, you know...
No, the thing is...
So, a huge shoutout to MSI for sponsoring today's stream.
I'm compiling shaders right now, for those who are wondering why we're not in the game yet.
I didn't realize... I keep forgetting that every new game now requires you to compile shaders.
So, that's what I'm waiting on at the moment.
But anyway, a huge shoutout to MSI for sponsoring today's stream.
MSI has a special collaboration regarding Monster Hunter Wild's launch date.
Where you purchase a monitor from MSI.
And I'm using one of their monitors right now.
You'll be able to get a copy of Monster Hunter Wild's plus $30 of Steam code.
So, basically, it's a little promotion that they're doing.
So, a huge shoutout to MSI.
They also provided me five game codes to give away to my Dragoons at the end of the stream.
So, if you don't have Monster Hunter Wild's yet, this might be a chance to be able to get a copy of Monster Hunter Wild's at the end of the stream.
So, there's gonna be a giveaway for that.
Anyway, so, MSI provided me a free game code for Monster Hunter Wild's.
But it was supposed to be for launch date.
But thing is, I also received a...
So, Capcom USA also reached out to me to provide me, you know, with the whole, like, the special limited edition creator merch package.
So, I got that.
And in there, you receive an early copy of the game as well.
So, I received an email from them and saying, you can stream this game starting at this time.
And I was like, oh, I already have the code.
But then they were like, we are providing you the early copy version.
So, then I was like, oh my god, wait.
So, I got two game codes.
But, obviously, I got the early access copy code too.
So, I was just like, oh my god, wait, okay.
So, obviously, you know, I used that just to make sure I could download the game and unpack everything.
But then I forgot.
I was like, I am so ready.
I'm so ready to get into the game instantly.
But then I forgot that the compile shaders.
So, that's what we're waiting on right now.
I'm stuck in the compiling shaders tab at the moment.
So, yeah, I fucked up.
So, my history of Monster Hunter.
I need you guys to know, there's gonna be a lot of backseating and a lot of people yelling at me.
Because the last time, I played Monster Hunter once in my life.
And not once, I only played one Monster Hunter game in my life.
And it is the PSP version in 2007.
And it was in Japanese.
Because it wasn't my game.
It was my dad's Monster Hunter game on the PSP.
So, I had no idea what to really do in that game.
When I did quests, because everything was in Japanese.
So, I just didn't know how the fuck to play the game.
But I still played the game.
I just did it by trial and error.
No, my dad did not understand Japanese.
But he can read the characters.
Some Chinese characters are similar to Japanese characters because of kanji.
So, he was able to read some of the text.
So, he could understand what to do.
So, I basically brute-forced my way to learning.
Sharpening the knives and everything.
But obviously, the only weapon I used was the twin knives.
Because it was the easiest to understand with my little brain.
It was the easiest to understand when I couldn't read the language.
Or understand what the fuck I was doing.
Because all I had to do was sharpen my blades.
And I knew how to do that.
I knew what the item was that sharpened the blade.
And then I knew how to feed myself.
And that's it.
So, when I had missions where you had to kill this monster.
Or specific monsters.
I didn't know what the fuck to do.
I didn't know because I can't read.
So, all the quests I did was...
I wasn't hunting at all.
All the quests I did in Monster Hunter when I didn't know what the fuck was going on.
Was gathering.
Because you know what I did for gathering quests?
I literally just picked up every item I could see.
Until the quest log was like, you've gathered one of the five.
And I was like, oh, it's this item.
I'm like, oh, okay, I got the item.
Or the quests where I had to kill the weaker monsters.
The ones that spawn the main dragons or whatever.
So, you're like, oh, you have to kill one out of five of the deers and stuff like that.
So, I just kill all the little guys.
Because if I see multiples, then I'd be like, okay, this is not a big boss.
So, I know they're not the big bosses because I have to kill five of them.
So, then I was like, okay, I gotta kill everything until it says one out of five.
So, I did that.
I just went and killed everything until one out of five.
I was like, I did it!
Yay!
I found it!
I found the monster!
So, that was how I played Monster Hunter in 2000.
I don't even remember if it was 2007.
I just know it was a 2007 game because I was looking through the covers.
I was like, which one was the game that I...
So, I...
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Can I get free coffee at the Monster Hunter Wild, please?
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you, Liete!
But yeah, like I said, that was the last...
That was the only Monster Hunter game I've ever played.
But I also have various...
But I love the cats.
I always... I have so much merch.
Not a lot of them, but I have random Monster Hunter merch.
Because I just love...
I just love the cats and the chibi monster designs.
Like the Palicos.
And then, you know, the chibi plushies they've done of the monsters?
I have some of those because I thought they were just really cute.
So, like, I have several of those.
That, like, just in my room.
Donut, thank you for the...
Welcome to Tomato Farm!
Welcome, welcome!
But yeah, today is the launch day of Monster Hunter Wild.
So, like I said, this is like my only experience with Monster Hunter.
So, I don't really know what weapons are good.
I don't really know, like, what the current generation of Monster Hunter is now.
Since, like, you know, my only experience was 2000.
The 2007 PSP game.
Should I play on a controller or do I play on mouse and keyboard?
I don't know.
Is it easier on mouse and keyboard?
Like, if I...
Apparently, there's guns?
Like, I don't know.
I've never... I've never, like...
I don't know.
So, I'm gonna need you guys to let me know how to play this game.
Cause, like, some of you guys were like, there's a gun in this game.
But, like, if there's guns, shouldn't I use mouse and keyboard then?
Like, wouldn't that make sense to use a mouse and keyboard if there's a gun?
Yeah, so, like, controller for melee.
Alright, do we...
Okay, I'm gonna...
I don't know.
Actually, we'll try mouse and keyboard for now.
And then we'll see how I feel.
We'll see how I feel.
Because I feel like if I'm gonna do melee, then I'll do controller.
But if I do end up liking the guns or, like, the bows or whatever the fuck they are...
Then I might use...
I might try and do...
Try and do M and K.
So, we'll see how it goes.
Cause if it's melee, then it would make sense that I use, like, controller.
Cause what am I aiming at?
I'm just fucking beating people up.
What am I aiming at?
Alright.
We finished unpacking.
Woah.
Also, sound, guys.
Make sure everything is okay.
But, yeah.
I heard the Palicos are, like, extremely cute, as always.
Which makes me happy.
English, please.
English.
Cause I'm not here to read.
Country.
Canada.
We're asking for our internal regarding legal compliance.
Don't worry, guys.
I was born in 1900.
How would they know?
Is your date of birth correct?
Yes.
Yeah, I've agreed to accept.
Because Monster started out with just controlling points.
I've heard M and K is alright for both.
Yeah, that's the thing.
Like, if I...
Oh, look at that.
Look at all that free DLC.
Yes.
I love free stuff.
I don't know what any of these things are.
My Oshi is a mega hag.
Awesome.
Next scene.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I have no idea what any of these things are.
But I love free stuff.
Yes.
Nice.
Okay, I agree.
I agree to accept.
I'm using keyboard layout.
Okay.
Do not...
Okay, sure.
I don't know.
Thank you for playing my favorite game series.
Oh, thank you for the first super chat.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Not so Deadpool.
Doki is not aiming kind of gun.
Wait, what do you mean?
What do you mean?
It's a name.
It's a gun.
It's always a display.
There's no difference between light and dark areas.
Okay, I'll just do two.
Maybe one.
What?
I don't know.
I can't...
While facing it, there's no...
Oh, so you're not supposed to see anything.
All right.
Facing it, there's no difference between white...
Okay, so it's supposed to be...
Okay.
Adjust the brightness of the screen until the symbol on the left is barely visible.
I mean, that's fine.
Audio mixing...
Oh, there's like voice chat, too.
I don't...
I don't trust...
If we play with dragoons today, I'm sorry.
I don't trust you guys.
You can always...
Fuck solo.
Why the fuck would I solo?
Lame.
Unity, thank you for the five gifted ships.
Thank you.
Again, thank you for the super chat.
Monster Hunter is one of my favorite games.
I hope you enjoy the game as much as us.
It'd be nice to see collab with other streamers playing the game, too.
Can't wait to see what weapon you use.
You know, like...
You know that all the Sloppy Sisters received a creator package?
I was thinking of like asking if they all want to try to do a...
Do a collab with Monster Hunter in the future.
She hate...
Alright, dragoons.
Do you guys...
Do you trust other dragoons?
Do you...
Do you trust the other dragoons?
No.
Alright, let's see.
I wonder what...
Oh, wait.
They have an arachnophobia assistant?
I wonder what it looks like, though.
Yes, with my life.
Camera shake.
I don't really have motion sickness, but like...
I might...
I'd definitely lower the camera shake, though.
For sure.
Whoa.
Monster Hunter Wilds.
Okay.
Menu text size.
Oh, okay.
Wait, can I not...
Subtitle.
Okay, large, because we're blind as fuck.
Speaker names.
Yes, please.
I'll forget their names if they don't tell me who they are.
I would 100.
No other dragoons, including Manny Airport Ninja.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I knew it.
I knew you guys don't trust the others.
I fucking knew it.
You guys can't lie to me.
Capped.
But how much?
How much is it capped?
60!
No wonder my frame...
No wonder I look great.
Okay, let's do like 144.
I don't have 144.
I have...
I have 200, but like...
I feel a little wild, you know?
I feel...
I feel less wild.
Wait, okay.
I feel less wild now.
That's crazy.
Oh my god, the moment it went to 144, I was like...
That was a little too wild, guys.
That was a little too wild.
It's okay.
Now...
Okay, let's do high.
I don't think we need ultra, right?
Hi Doki, it's my birthday!
I remember seeing you last year playing Batman.
Love your streams and have so for years.
You're my Kamiyoshi.
I look forward to another happy year.
Thank you for making my days brighter and inspiring me to do better.
Thank you for the magenta super, Broku!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Broku.
Yeah, happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Okay, let's get the motion blur off.
Alright, guys, I figured I had to be less wild.
I know it says Monster Hunter is wild, but we gotta be a little less wild, guys.
Just a little bit less wild.
Alright, voice volume...
95, because I don't trust it.
Play audio?
Wait, feline language?
What can I set?
Voice typeset?
Oh, okay, to the voice typeset.
Okay, then that should be fine.
Everything should be fine.
Alright.
That's everything, right?
Alright, we can start game.
Wait, does it talk in English?
Wait, they can either speak English or meow?
Oh my god, I would want them to meow.
Wait, the cats?
That's...
That's a crime.
The cats can talk now?
If I wanted a cat that could talk to me...
I would have just...
Who taught... I know, who the fuck taught them English?
I was just like, what would I do if I wanted a cat that could talk?
I'd just get Garfield.
Oh wait, there's no audio?
What?
Is there audio now?
There's audio on my end.
Is it actually muted?
It says there's audio.
Oh, it's just low, okay.
I'll push it up.
Okay, let me know if it's better.
I pushed it up a little.
Oh shit, what time is it?
Oh, fuck!
Okay guys, I'm gonna mute myself real quick.
I might have to pick up my medic...
Uber eats some medicine.
I
forgot.
I forgot my medicine.
I forgot my medicine is here.
Uber eats some NyQuil.
No, I wanna watch the cutscene too!
What?!
I wanna watch it!
Don't worry, they can wait like 2 minutes.
Is this a long cutscene?
No, Taixin!
Wait, can I pause it?
Wait, I can pause it?
Wait, I don't have N-key.
I don't have N-key!
God, I need to get my other keyboard.
Wait.
Oh my god.
Where is it?
Okay.
Okay, I'll be right back, guys.
I'll be right back!
Okay, I'm back!
Sorry, guys!
I actually forgot I Uber-eated some...
I forgot!
I was like, what's caught me?
It's like 9.30pm.
What the fuck is caught me?
And I was like, oh my god, my Uber-eats order.
Sorry, people have been like, why has she been like, why is she moving?
It's been so long!
Sorry, I had to get my cough drops and...
Oh, I forgot to un-end this.
Oh, wait.
I was running out of cough drops and then my friend was recommending...
My friend was like, you should really get some NyQuil and DayQuil.
It'll really help you.
And I was like, okay.
Alright.
Let's go.
I can't believe they can talk.
Who the fuck gave them permission?
Like, if I wanted someone that can talk, I'd just recruit a regular human.
Like, why would I get cats anyway?
Like, what's the point of having a...
What's the point of having a cat servant?
It'd be like...
Like, I don't understand.
I'll just get a regular person.
Like...
The reason why I got cats is they can meow.
They can meow cutely.
Who gave them rights to talk?
Like...
They can meow.
I didn't give you permission to talk.
I want to understand.
No, you don't.
If you could understand your dog, you would be the most annoying piece of shit ever.
What if every time he's barking, he's like, fuck you!
Fuck you!
Yeah!
That's your dog?
The Forbidden Lands?
Oh, more overall volume?
Okay, I got you.
Brought it up even more.
Apparently, they're supposed to not be able to talk.
They're supposed to like, not be able to talk in English.
This is like the first time in a Monster Hunter game that they can actually talk in English.
Or like, have a language that you can understand.
If your dog can talk to you, you won't think they're cute.
That's all I'm saying.
Alright, honey.
Oh, I can like, adjust it?
I don't wanna be a man or a woman.
That's like, that's always the hardest part.
Like, do I wanna be a man or a woman?
I don't know.
Alright.
What's sexy?
I should create my You're right.
You're right.
I was gonna say, what armor looks better?
Cause like, sometimes like, the armor looks different on like, the guy and the girl.
So like, which armor looks better?
Alright, we'll make me.
I'll make me.
We'll use a preface first.
Damn.
Since I was born in the 1900's...
Wait!
Since I doxxed my age and I was born in the 1900's?
Okay, let's look at the hairstyle.
Alright, do they have my hair?
Let's see.
Oh, it's not?
Okay, it's not locked this time.
Yeah, cause it used to be.
I remember it in the 2007 version.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Have you seen the clips of Bunny and the Talking Dog?
Talks by pressing a word button.
Yeah, and it's wrong.
No, I'm joking.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, they don't have my hairstyle.
I mean, they have...
God, this looks so wrong.
But like, fuck it.
They have Retro Turkey.
Fuck it.
Okay.
Guys, I can't.
I'm sorry.
I doxxed...
I doxxed
my...
Oh, sorry.
This looks like... Does this look like I was born in 1900, guys?
I think it does.
Wrinkles?
Hell yeah.
Yeah, I need to know.
I need you guys to know.
Alright, there we go.
I mean, I might as well.
I doxxed myself.
It needs to look 125.
Fun!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Sorry for the bad timing on the previous super chat.
Anyways, happy hunting.
Gonna lurk and we're excited to see what weapon you choose.
Alright, I'm trying to get close to the light.
Okay, like, you know, the older you get the less eyebrows you're gonna...
I don't know.
Eyebrow shape.
Let's see.
What shape do I have?
This one.
Okay, and then...
Eyelash color.
I mean, it should be yellow, right?
Yeah.
Like, oh my gosh.
It looks fucking...
Okay.
There we go.
So...
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, is this green?
Oh my god, it's so muted.
It's like I'm old.
It's muted with age or some shit.
Whoa.
Let's put it at 6.
Oh, I can edit the right eye?
Let's fucking aimbot time.
Wait, that's the wrong one.
Um...
Ah, fuck it.
No, I actually like the green.
No aimbot.
Wait, if I'm gonna use the gun, then maybe...
Maybe if I'm gonna use the gun, but like...
It's on the wrong side, but I can't be bothered to fix it.
Okay, I'll...
I'll fix it.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
That should be fine.
Um, eye shape.
Oh, I can change the eye shape too?
Okay.
There we go.
You can literally... Okay, there we go.
That's fine.
I don't really care about the eye shape.
I mean, I don't really care about the nose either.
I mean, like, that...
That's basically it.
Like...
Wait, I realized the hairstyle does not match if I use...
Uh, if I do this.
Oh, but there's like no other hairstyle.
That's like my current hairstyle though.
Yeah, none of them is like my current one.
I guess like...
Like that.
No?
Yeah, none of them have my current hairstyle.
Cause, why do I look old?
Because I was born in 1900s.
Okay, I doxed my age today.
Um, on the confirm your age.
26?
Is it actually?
No, I don't know.
Spikely one looks...
Like, oh wait, there's this too?
Uh...
I could be like...
Independent women hairstyle.
The classic, like...
The strong independent women.
I don't know why they always...
There's always this hairstyle for that.
And there's like...
Horizon Dawn.
Uh...
I don't know.
Fuck it, we'll just go with...
Fuck it, we'll just...
Oh wait, and then there's Kingdom Hearts or Final Fantasy.
Um...
We'll just go with...
Fuck it, we'll just go with the ponytail.
Or not ponytail, the pigtails.
Uh, three is close?
Is it actually?
Three?
Is it though?
Three...
It's already at the ten though.
It's already at ten.
Nah, I'm gonna go back to the pigtails.
Nah, I think the pigtails look the best.
Alright.
Mouth.
Mouth position.
Can I be happier?
Oh, I can be.
I mean, that makes me look older.
Which is what I'm aiming for.
Yay!
Why is my teeth grey?
Oh my god.
Okay, I brush my teeth.
What the heck?
What the fuck?
Teeth stain?
Yeah, no teeth stain, please.
There we go.
I brush my teeth.
Alright, facial hair.
Wait, there's beard type?
Oh my god, no.
Face shape.
I think it's fine.
Physique.
Okay, muscle mass.
Um...
Nick, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Um...
Faith, thank you for the superchat!
Thank you, thank you!
I'm a muscle grandma.
That's right.
Get yourself a grandma that never stops lifting.
I'm a muscle granny.
That's fucking right.
What the fuck is size?
Oh, I thought...
You know...
Guys, I thought size...
Was...
Something we all know.
I thought...
You know, we all thought...
We all thought it was that, guys.
I'll make it so I have like...
Eye bags.
Okay, is that eye bags?
Okay.
Is it?
I wanna make sure people know that I'm not okay.
I'm not okay.
Wait, is that it?
Is physique literally just muscle?
Alright, there we go.
Alright, bring up the volume a little bit more.
No problem.
If my dog started speaking English, he would have to start paying his share of the rent.
He ain't a pet no more.
That's exactly!
I'm not here for a roommate!
Thank you for the superchat, Gordon.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
That's me.
Beard type.
Oh wait, how do I confirm?
Hair base color.
Yeah, everything looks good.
Wait, oh, can I change my clothes color?
Oh, I do that.
Hair accent.
Oh, I wanna change my clothes.
Oh my god, that's way too much customization.
Okay, what do I wear again?
I started to look at myself.
Like, I'm gonna take these clothes off anyway in the end, right?
Like, okay, that sounded really bad.
But like, you guys know what?
Fuck it.
I'll be swapping clothes later.
It's fine.
I don't need it.
Oh, whoa.
Nice.
I'll be swapping clothes anyway.
It'll be fine.
Oh, I can select my voice too?
Oh, nice.
Wait, how do I listen to this?
How do I listen to my voice?
It doesn't even tell me.
Uh...
Where the fuck is my voice?
It's a different menu?
Where is it?
Where the fuck is the menu for it?
Oh, I have to go back?
Okay, wait.
I'm a little worried.
What happens if I do save?
Okay, I saved my design.
Okay, I just gotta make sure.
Oh, there it is!
I see it!
Okay.
How the fuck did I get here?
Okay, let's do it.
Let's be normal.
Let's...
Yeah!
Alright, I'm cool with that.
Alright, let's be normal.
Wait, can I have different innerwear?
Oh, shit.
Let's be very normal.
Wait, actually...
Uh...
Ooh, yeah.
No, I definitely want this.
How else am I gonna show my grand bod?
How?
How else?
Tights?
No, we don't need to show that.
What's starting armor?
Hope?
None.
What if I just have no armor?
Ooh, chainmail.
Ooh, I like the leather one.
Wait, do I want... No, I want the leather armor.
Yeah!
Yeah, let's go, granny!
Let's go!
Just...
That's right!
Uh, Brady, thank you for the superchat!
Thank you, thank you!
Hi, Doki!
Yesterday was my birthday!
And I hope you're feeling better!
Thank you for the superchat!
Thank you, thank you!
I had a great birthday yesterday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Brady!
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Alright, let's make Doki amber doge.
Oh my god, wait.
I can make a cuter cat.
Like an actual...
Wait.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
I'm so, so sorry.
But like, there's so much...
Okay.
Okay, we can make Doki amber doge.
We can do it.
Wait, I can make Garfield!
You're so right!
I'm sorry.
I'm gonna make Garfield.
Okay, this is Garfield's ears.
That is...
To foot your line language.
You're not allowed to talk.
Wait.
Oh, you are definitely...
You're definitely not allowed to talk.
I'm not letting you have...
I'm not giving you the right to talk anymore.
You guys hear that?
That is...
That is wrong.
That is so wrong.
They sound the same.
This is the same type!
Alright, let's make Garfield.
Okay, Garfield is short-haired.
Ear size...
Okay, I think four was right.
Four was definitely right.
And then he has the...
Oh, he has...
He has these whiskers, right?
Yeah, these are the whiskers on top.
There we go.
And then...
Garfield doesn't actually talk!
He...
It's cause like...
Okay, the reason why you think Garfield can talk...
Is that he's talking to other animals.
But John doesn't know...
Doesn't hear what he says.
That's why it's thought bubbles.
Guys...
Know your Garfield lore!
I can't believe you don't know your Garfield...
Are you really trying to um...
Actually be the number one Garfield fan right now?
Are you...
I can't believe you would say...
You were like...
Garfield...
No, you don't know shit!
Okay, this is Garfield's pattern.
I know that for sure.
Okay, um...
This is Garfield's... Oh, but I love the little...
Okay, but he has like...
Stripes though, that's the thing.
So like, it should be this.
Okay, the base color is orange.
So we need to get the right orange, guys.
Um...
Oh yeah, this is the right orange.
And then the pattern accent...
What is this?
Okay, this is also the same orange.
Oh, this looks so wrong.
I'm not gonna...
Oh my god.
Okay, let's just make it all orange so I can figure...
Okay, wait, I need to... Let me pull...
Let me pull it up.
I need to figure this out.
Okay.
Okay, this is like the best I can do.
Like this.
Okay, there we go.
I mean, it sort of looks like Garfield.
We have Garfield at home.
I am trying my best right now!
Okay.
And then...
His pattern.
I'll make it like...
I'll make it like dark orange.
So it looks less wrong.
There we go.
It sort of looks like Garfield, right?
I mean, sort of, yeah.
Okay, maybe like...
Maybe if I...
Make it more orange.
Yeah!
See?
That's Garfield!
Don't even try my best!
That's...
That's Garfield!
Look, I can't make him fatter!
Literally, that's like the only pattern where it works, guys!
That's literally the only pattern that works with Garfield.
Okay.
I'm trying!
It's so hard!
Okay.
Okay, maybe it's this.
But like, it's yellow!
It's like a yellowish... yeah, like this.
There we go.
Sort of like Garfield.
Like, great value Garfield.
Netflix version.
Burrito, thank you for the superchat.
I'm trying!
I'm trying so hard!
Okay, there we go.
There's my Garfield.
Alright.
Maybe it'll look better if he's longer hair.
No, he does not look better.
There we go.
Now!
I mean...
Come on!
That's Garfield right there.
Okay.
Alright, let's go through the tail types.
That's...
That's basically him.
There we go.
Now!
Now it looks like him, right?
Okay.
What is marking type?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Okay, let's see.
Let me look at this.
Um...
I mean, if I like...
I guess we can make it just like...
like that, right?
And then we'll make it...
Okay, no.
That doesn't work.
That does not work.
Okay, we don't do any markings.
Okay, there we go.
I mean...
I can resize and move those.
Resize what?
Oh, I can move.
Oh, I can move this!
Okay.
Wait, I figured it out.
I'm looking at Garfield right now.
I feel like... No, I think this works.
Honestly.
It's basically him.
Guys, I can't make him fatter!
If I could, I would!
The best I could do is make his cheeks fatter!
That's the best I can!
Feed him!
Please!
He's so hungry!
Feed him!
Okay, how about like...
Oh, this is like... John, I'm so hungry.
I'm sorry, John.
I was just so hungry.
Okay, this is Garfield, but like he got found a catnip.
Okay, here.
There you go.
Garfield, but he found catnip.
Alright, iris colors.
What is... What are Garfield's eye color?
Green, right?
Yeah, there you go.
I'm so hungry, John.
I'm so hungry.
Okay, there you go.
Now he's cute.
Now he's cute!
Guys, look at that.
Look at that.
He's very hungry, but like, now he's pretty cute!
Alright, nice.
We did it.
We figured it out, guys.
We got Garfield at home.
I am trying my best right now!
I am...
Look at him!
Look, there's Garfield!
Yesterday was Leah's birthday.
Can you wish her a happy birthday too?
Of course!
Like, who else does?
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Enter your name.
Okay.
Cool.
Is the name not Doki?
Okay, yes.
Enter your palico's name.
Garfield at home.
Okay, wait.
Wait, okay.
Walmart Garfield.
Not Garfield!
Wait, what should I do?
Alright.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday to Gar...
I mean, Leah!
Happy birthday to you!
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Ninja, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Has opportunity to make dad in game.
Chooses to make Garfield instead.
This is why he loves the babysitter.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Not Garfield!
Is this name okay?
Yes.
Select the amount of tutorials.
Just all of them.
Okay.
Start the game with these, yes.
There's my Garfield!
It's okay, I get like a dog, right?
Do I get a dog in this game?
I'll just name that dog after dad.
That's me in 1900s.
Hello!
I'm sorry, every time I look at myself.
We don't have to raise it up.
That's so old!
I'm so locked in!
No, dog Chocobo instead.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I'm young at heart, guys.
Look at my pigtails.
I'm so tired.
I'm feeling sad.
I feel like a 130 year old granny.
I raised the volume up.
I'll bring the music down later.
A monster?
A monster in Monster Hunter?
No fucking way!
Oh my god, me?
It's because of my experience, right?
I know!
Lead hunter level 1?
Bro, I turned on every tutorial.
How am I the lead hunter?
Every tutorial was turned on.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Who are you?
This is my cat, Garfield.
Sorry.
Your daughter looks like a mother who tries to act young.
To bond with her daughter.
Thank you for the superchat, Sleepy.
Thank you, thank you.
Am I back in Sandland?
Do I ever leave Sandland?
I wonder what Garfield would say if I turned on the voice.
What would he be like?
He's like, hey!
I wonder what he'd say.
Oh, where are they chasing?
What is that?
Oh my god, it's a child!
Am I going to steal her pet?
I hate Monday.
I'm going to steal...
I'm going to carjack your ride.
It's GTA now.
Get the child off of that ride.
Wait, there were subtitles to his meows?
Okay, that's pretty funny.
Wait, the child's gone.
Wait, where did the child go?
Oh shit, I'm playing!
Oh, okay guys.
Oh, I can't pause?
Oh my god, it's a multiplayer game!
I can't pause!
Oh, this is a different bird?
Oh my god, you can't pause!
It's multiplayer now!
It's online!
This is so weird!
What do I do?
Oh, I just jump up.
Oh my god, the sensitivity is so high.
Okay, I was not ready to not pause.
Wait, I can fly!
Come on, Garfiel, let's go.
Let's take her car.
Oh, okay, well I guess she's dead now.
Wait, grab the screamer car?
Aim?
Yeah, I did it.
Wait, what?
Did I do it?
I did it!
Alright, nice.
Alright, Garfiel, you can drive, right?
Of course he can.
Of course he can drive.
Oh, I can kill him.
Okay, aim, shoot.
Okay.
And then I drag him in.
And then I go...
There we go.
But just, like, do that.
Yeah, alright.
Oh, I don't have unlimited!
It's not unlimited, guys!
Guys, it's not unlimited!
Whoops!
I...
Guys!
Guys, it's not unlimited!
It's like pew pew!
Pew pew!
You don't say!
Guys, now I know.
Nice.
Easy.
Alright.
Okay.
I realized, like, at the bottom, right?
It was, like, one out of six.
And I was like, one out of...
Wait, what do you mean one out of six?
Check out the monsters.
Ten!
Alright, nice.
Oh, I got my blade!
Don't worry.
I have 120 years of experience.
Sage, welcome to the mail farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Who taught you how to drive, little girl?
There are people here.
Oh, you speak...
You speak English!
Yeah,
what is it?
Oh, shit.
I didn't realize the voice did not match at all.
Every time I look at her, I can't...
I don't think he's alive.
I'll be your new brother.
We'll leave some supplies for you.
I'll keep an eye on these two.
We're moving out.
Alright, music and sound effects by 15.
Okay.
Why the fuck he doesn't understand you?
Come with me, okay?
Oh, it's the little plushie that I had!
How the fuck would he understand you?
Yeah.
Yeah, of course the cats do.
The cats literally build a fucking village.
The dog speaks English?!
Who allowed them?
Alright.
Okay, let's fix this.
God, it was so weird.
I was like, what the fuck?
I couldn't...
Let's see...
Options...
God, that was so weird.
I can't pause the game.
Uh, BGM volume...
Turn it down to 67.
Voice volume is maxed up.
We know they're friends.
Alright, uh...
Alright, that should be good.
Yeah, but you have to click pause for that.
I'm not used to that.
Okay, let me grab the sensitivity.
It was so high.
Holy shit.
Okay.
Keyboard and mouse.
Where is...
Is there...
Is there sensitivity?
Oh, camera sensitivity.
Uh...
We'll do it at maybe like 6.
Maybe that'll be better.
No, it's still a little bit too high.
Wait, is this the sensitivity?
No, it's not.
It's not the sensitivity.
Still pretty high.
Uh...
Yeah, but you don't have mouse...
Oh, camera shake.
Let me put that down.
I don't like the camera shake.
I guess it's this, right?
Aiming?
Yeah, but like...
Where else would it be, though?
It's not camera.
Controllers and all...
Is it this one?
There's no sensitivity here.
There's no...
There's no sensitivity on this.
It is?
Scroll down?
No, this is...
Oh, maybe it's page 2.
Oh!
No.
No, it's still the same.
Yeah, because this is...
This is for controller, and we don't need controller.
JK, we lied.
I know.
I'll just turn this down.
And see if that works.
Usually, you turn this down.
It should be fine.
Uh...
It's like, I don't like how...
That's alright.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh, I can adjust to that.
I think that's fine, right?
That should be fine.
Let's double check if I saved everything.
Alright.
Hello!
No?
Okay.
Not yet.
Uh...
More quick, the best offense is a good...
That...
Oh, wait, I prefer to take my aim at my target from a distance.
Yeah, that's true.
I like to switch between ammo.
I prefer to wait.
I like to weave around while keeping...
I like to wait for it to open and then attack.
I like to switch between...
I like this one, the first one.
Light bowgun?
I'll pick a weapon up myself.
Alright, let's try.
Alright.
That...
With mobile...
What was it?
Someone said I should try gunlance.
Should I try light bowgun?
With mid-range, good for quick fire.
Rapid fire lets you expand energy to fire multiple rounds of ammo.
Guarding.
None.
Okay.
Has a variety of arrow attacks and focus on mobility.
Charging arrows will increase size and allows you to move away.
Guarding.
None.
Gunlance is fun.
Long-reaching thrust.
No shellfire.
Has low mobility but great guarding capabilities.
And supports a variety...
Ooh.
Guarding capabilities.
Hmm.
Has a powerful long...
Um...
Long-distance, short-based, expands energy to fire low mobility but...
I wanna try...
I'll try light bowgun.
I'm gonna try this.
I wanna see what that is like.
Or the bow.
Okay, guys.
Light bowgun or the bow, guys?
You wanna shoot and dodge?
We don't block in this house, exactly.
I'll try...
I'll try light bowgun first, then.
Uh...
Bow is more fun?
Is it actually?
Charging arrows will increase their power size and allows you to move away.
Which one is more fun?
And test both?
Okay, I'll test both.
I'll test both.
Oh, equipped it.
What am I...
What am I doing?
How do I bring it out?
How do I bring out my weapon?
Oh, there we go.
Reload.
Oh, there it is!
Okay.
Aim, focus, switch modes, evade.
Uh, focus blast?
Oh, I see.
Okay.
And then...
Switch modes.
What's my mode?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
What's this mode?
And this is normal ammo.
Okay.
Let's see.
Special, R, and F?
Oh, shit!
What the fuck is that?
What is that?
What did I make?
Oh, it's a mine!
Oh, okay.
I was like, the fuck did I make?
Alright, I wanna try the bow now.
Hello, ma'am.
How do I try the bow?
Uh...
I wanna try the bow.
Let's see how I feel.
Uh, okay.
Aim slinger, ready weapon.
Okay.
What the fuck?
What if, like...
Okay, if I hold it straight up...
Quick shot.
Quick shot...
Dragon piercer?
Oh my god!
That's a big-ass bow!
Hellstorm?
Charging sidestep.
Charging sidestep?
How do I use...
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Jesus Christ, there's so many!
I need a barrel?
There's a barrel?
Oh, it's out of range.
Okay.
Uh...
Charging sidestep.
Quick shot.
I don't know if I like...
Bow is easier?
You don't need to farm ammo?
Ooh, maybe.
I think I like the bow actually more.
Charge shot, then press F.
Oh!
Jesus Christ!
What am I looking at?
What am I- Holy shit!
There's so many combos!
Oh my god!
I don't know!
They both look really interesting.
I can't tell.
They both look incredibly interesting.
How do I get this out of my screen?
Alright.
Alright, guys.
Bow and lobe, I don't know.
They both look pretty interesting, so I can't tell.
I don't know.
I can carry both?
I like both of them.
Because one is a gun.
Which one?
Am I switching mode?
Because one is a gun.
And then there's like...
A melee weapon?
Okay, let's see.
So many combos!
It's Capcom!
Oh my god, it's another fighter.
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Oh, the classic.
This is the one that I know.
This was the classic.
All I did was just do this.
And then... Demon Mode!
Boom, boom, boom, boom.
And I missed the barrel.
Demon Mode!
This was the easiest one.
This is what I know.
It was so easy.
This is literally the easiest one.
It still works.
Okay.
I'll try bow.
I'll do it.
Okay.
Tap mount to mount your move automatically towards your objective.
You will return to auto-move after some time.
Or you can reactivate it with tap.
Okay, auto-move with tap.
Wait, actually...
Can I get off?
Oh, I can't.
They won't let me.
Okay.
Auto-move.
You move for me.
Alright, go!
Move for me!
Oh, I can pick up mushrooms!
Let me pick it up.
Alright.
Hello?
What did he say, Garfield?
Oh, I can?
Oh, shit!
Oh, is that the brother?
Hello!
Woah!
Getting a little freaky!
The Chaka Kabar!
You know, I'm just confused why he licked him instead of just eating him straight up.
Like, that's just a hobby.
Like, he's definitely playing with his food.
Oh, shit!
I did that.
Bro, just like, take down his like, the little packages that he has.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I trained for this.
Gather and consume.
Don't worry.
Um...
Ready weapon.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, I got this.
Oh, fuck!
Oh, shit!
Okay, don't worry, I got this.
Garfield, help me!
I can't do combos!
Okay, don't worry.
Don't worry, I don't know how to do combos yet.
I'm just trying to figure out how to survive.
Oh, shit, no!
I forgot about stamina!
Oh, shit, Garfield!
I forgot about stamina, Garfield!
Okay, don't worry, I got this.
Don't worry.
Okay, good.
Good bait, Garfield.
Good bait.
Okay, nice.
Oh, shit!
Stamina!
Please, shoot!
Alright.
Nice.
Good job!
Oh, I need to stop doing that.
Okay, hellstorm.
Nice.
What can I do now?
Don't worry.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna do it all the way here.
Oh, I could have...
Oh, that's alright.
I definitely know what I'm doing, guys.
Don't worry.
I think...
I think I know what I'm doing.
Repeating attack in the same part opens a wound.
Wait, he has a wound?
Use focus mode to target?
Oh, it's right here.
Nice, I got it.
His leg is broken.
Garfield, please!
Wait, what the fuck?
There we go.
I got it.
That's right.
I missed all of those shots somehow.
I don't know how.
Guys, do you think my one hit damage is doing enough?
He's alright.
Look at him.
He's full HP.
He's so healthy.
Nice.
Shift while holding to perform a focus strike.
If the attack hits a wound, it'll destroy it.
Okay.
There we go.
I figured it out.
I think I'm doing it.
I'm sorry!
I keep trying to fucking...
I'm trying to feed!
Get your fucking bow out!
Wait, did he...
Is he gone?
There's just no one firing from this system.
So try to keep the reticle orange.
Wait, is he gone?
Apply a coating by consuming the trick arrow.
Select coating.
Oh, I can select coatings.
Oh my god.
I want this item.
Give me a sec.
I'm trying to...
How do I pick it up?
How do I...
Oh, there it is.
Oh, I have to sheath my weapon.
I hope Garfiel's okay.
Garfiel, are you okay there?
I hope he's okay.
Oh.
I'll take that.
Deliberate.
Hold E to press to shoot a trace.
The next arrow should attract a trace.
Oh!
Oh shit, Garfiel, I'm sorry!
Oh, I'm sorry!
Oh, I hope he's okay!
My bad!
I was looting!
I'm so looting!
I'm sorry!
Oh shit.
John!
John, please!
I was looting!
I'm sorry!
Oh shit.
Oh no.
I have an SOS flare?
You can request help from our fire and hunting party consists of a certain amount of passes after it, but no other support hunters will come to your aid from other units to help you hunt.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I think I'll need it.
How do I do it?
What?
Where's my SOS?
Control, open.
How do I...
Oh, there it is.
Alright.
Help me.
Okay.
Guess I don't need help.
Alright, mining time.
Okay.
Well.
I'll need help, guys.
Let's kill these guys.
Oh, you should be dead, right?
Can I farm you?
Oh shit, I should grab...
I should kill him first.
Alright.
Game said no help.
No help.
Okay.
Oh,
there you go.
Okay, let's kill these guys first, though.
Let's kill these guys first.
Alright.
Goodbye.
Okay, now we can do this.
That's right!
That's fucking right!
Get hunted!
Oh shit.
Jesus Christ.
This guy takes forever to kill.
Go Garfield, go!
Okay, wait.
Oh, fuck!
Dodged.
Don't worry.
I have Garfield to take my shots for me.
Garfield, please!
No, he licked me!
Okay.
We got this.
How
is he still alive?
Wait, where did these mosquitoes come from?
Alright.
Am I doing it?
I can't tell.
Guys, am I doing okay?
Oh shit!
No, I am.
No, I am 100% doing okay.
Look at that.
Oh my god!
Okay, that was cool.
Oh!
And I can do it again.
Oh, and again!
And again!
Wait, wait, wait.
Get back over here.
Wait, okay.
Don't worry.
I am figuring this out, guys.
He is running back like a pussy.
Get back here, you pussy.
Back over here.
Fight back!
Wait.
Give me a sec.
I am going to mind your friend right here.
Alright, okay.
Bring up the game volume by...
Alright.
Game volume by...
Up by 7.
And then...
Sound effects and music down.
Okay.
By 10.
Alright, nice.
That should be good.
Alright, Garfield, let's go.
Let's kill this guy.
What a fucking pussy.
We don't need our bird.
He is like right there.
Oh, he is dead.
How do I kill him in his sleep?
I do.
What do I do?
What do I just do?
Is that fucked?
Okay.
Nice.
That was pretty fucked up.
Never saw it coming.
Let's go.
That shot right there.
Nice.
Good shot.
They never see it coming.
That's right.
The best part.
Killing them in no honor.
Toki.
That wasn't even a 1v1.
What the fuck?
Alright, go.
Go.
Where does my tab tell me to go to?
Oh, I can end quest immediately.
Murdered while sleeping.
Just casually blew his head off.
I think he needs an ibuprofen.
AKB, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, I think...
I think I learned a lot from that.
I think I did pretty well for my first hunt.
This is the hunter way.
Exactly.
I think I did really well for my first hunt.
Alright.
I have auto-movement.
I did it.
I made it.
I did it, guys.
I killed him.
He's just like, what?
Yeah, I killed him in a sleep.
I'm a hot grandma, that's how.
Hot and strong.
Do my six pack.
You wanna see my six pack?
Little boy.
With the power of high.
High power.
Don't kid, no.
Imagine if they could talk.
That'd be so wrong.
And I would make sure that would never happen.
Yeah,
imagine.
No, no.
In my world, they never evolved past that.
This is a pretty well protected spot.
We could do a lot worse for an interim camp.
This way.
Let the cat speak.
I'm telling you, we just need some space.
She's fine.
But she needs...
Which we're perfectly capable of.
Nona!
Huh?
Hey, Cy!
You're okay!
Thank the winds.
Stop preventing their progress.
If they learn to talk, what's gonna stop them from hunting us?
Guys, I was born in a different time.
I was born in 1900s, guys.
And I grew up in the village.
My name is Nona.
It's wonderful to meet you.
I'm Alma.
The others and I are here on a search.
We're from a place far out west.
Back when cats couldn't talk.
Guys.
Back in my day, the cats couldn't talk.
Oh, they spoke in meows!
It's Rhyme!
You mean my bow?
It's a fucking bow!
Do you not have bows?
Like, it's just a giant fucking bow!
It's not that special!
I didn't understand it, but it was like a giant fucking gun lancer.
Do you not use tools?
How do you make your clothes?
They never seen a giant bow, Doki.
It's literally a bow, but they made it bigger.
Like, what's the difference?
Okay, what's your village?
Slurp, thank you for the superchat, thank you, thank you.
I'm putting a lot of you in front of me, that's my Doki!
Thank you for the superchat, thank you, thank you.
We better weed on him, because it's impractical!
I don't remember ever hearing that name before, but her elder, she might know something.
Alright, can you tell us more about your... yeah.
It must be a village of pacifists.
Should be easy to take down.
Oh my god, you're right!
I could take over this village with my giant fucking bow!
Oh my god, they're defenseless!
It's time!
I'm not just hunting monsters!
I'm here to expand an empire!
God, he's... why don't we have a look around base camp?
Who taught you how to talk, Garfield?
Who gave you subtitles, Garfield?
You're just here to be cute!
Alright, obtain new award, obtain new backgrounds.
Nice!
Wait, I should have, like, extra armor now, right?
It's just a thought, Bubbles!
Nice meeting you!
Okay, what's this?
It was me, Barry!
I gave your cat subtitles!
What is this?
Alright, uh... what's your role?
Yeah, what's your job here?
Okay...
Can I recruit more cats?
I know, like, in other games, you can, like, grab more cats to send out for quests.
Only get one cat?
Man, back in the 1900s, I could have multiple cats.
Now we just get one cat.
Okay, Doki.
The high performance barrel punch is a perfect trainer to practice using different weapons.
Huh?
You used to be able to, like... I was gonna say you used to be able to buy more cats, but I realized that sounded so bad.
I'm sorry!
I was like, but it was true in the other games!
You can, like, improve your cats!
No, cause, like, they'll have stronger cats that you can buy!
So, like, you can get stronger cats!
Like, it's not bad!
It's in the game!
It's in the game, I swear to God!
I swear to God, you can... it's true!
It's not me, it's the game!
It sounds so bad!
They're cats!
You all buy cats!
You don't judge me!
You all pay for your cats!
You're a paid cat and you bought that cat!
Doki, stop talking.
Um, actually, I think... Oh, so you kidnap cats out in the wild!
How is that better than what I do?
At least I pay them a wage!
Like, at least I employ them!
You just pick up a random cat off the streets!
What if that cat has a family?
I'm okay.
I was so surprised when you jumped off the boat onto that bird thing!
That was amazing!
Apologies with tears wet!
Thank you for the superchat!
Thank you, thank you!
Okay, tell me about... Okay, I don't want to learn more about you.
I want to know more about the cats.
So my Oshichi made graduation.
Thank you for the superchat!
Thank you, thank you!
Yes, Garfield gets paid!
Garfield, are you happy?
Look at that!
Look at him carrying all my loot!
He's so happy!
Look at him!
He's happy!
I even clothed him!
Some of them are naked!
Look at him!
He's wearing pants!
Look at this cat!
At least I gave my cat pants!
Look at me!
I am civilized!
I am a civilized cat owner!
Look at this cat!
Whoever owns this cat doesn't even wear pants!
Look at him!
He's happy here!
He's happy!
No, he's not!
Do you love me, Garfield?
That's right!
You love me, don't you?
That's right, Garfield!
Follow me!
Out of your own free will and nothing else!
Out of your free will that you will follow me!
Welcome back, Hunter!
Looking good out there!
Thanks for looking after Nata and the other kid.
Oh, I'm sure about that.
What can I say?
I come in handy.
Hello!
Everything's set and ready to go.
It's not ideal, but I can make do.
Wearing three layers in the desert.
What?
Oh, she makes me the weapons.
She turned off speech so they don't talk back?
That is not true!
I turned off speech because it's wrong that they could talk.
And that is not a bad thing!
Okay?
It's just not right!
A hunter's armor is made of five parts.
Each armor piece has two versions.
Choose whichever looks best on your hunter.
Will forge later.
This is wishlist.
Armor made from chairs with higher defense.
That doesn't make it!
You guys are fucking liars!
I know!
Majority of you guys turned off the cat's speech!
I know you guys turned it off!
I know you guys did!
Don't fucking lie to me!
Oh, there we go.
What can I make?
What would I want to make?
Oh, I like this one.
That's cute.
Should I make one?
You guys are fucking liars if it's on.
Should I buy them or should I buy it now?
Cat callouts are actually useful?
The fuck are they gonna call out?
Okay.
Should I?
Alright, I'll just grab the helmet.
I think the helmet's cute.
They are palicos.
Let them talk.
No, I would never want a talking animal because I know they're gonna say some dumb shit.
I know they're gonna, like, if they are allowed to talk, they're just gonna scream at me.
Let's see.
Oh, I actually like this.
I'm gonna buy.
I'm gonna get this.
Nice.
How does she turn a blade into a helmet?
That's a good question.
How does she turn a blade into a fucking jacket?
I like it.
Alright, and then...
Actually, I think I like this one more.
I like this one.
She's just that good.
Oh, I do have free stuff.
Wait, why am I spending money?
Wait, I have free...
Fuck, okay.
That's fine.
Wait, you're right.
I do have free...
I have the DLC!
Okay, um...
Oh, I guess I couldn't.
Wait,
how did I preview?
Oh, gee.
Oh, that's cute!
Is it stronger?
Oh, it is!
It has less thunder resistance.
I mean, I could give you a stronger melee.
I'm gonna give you a better weapon, Garfield.
Yeah.
How do I skip this?
Okay, yeah, I was like, I do not need a...
Wait, let me look at my free shit.
Like, what am I doing?
I have free stuff.
Let me change my pants.
Wait, none of these are good.
What is these?
Hope Coin.
Oh, wait!
Where's my free stuff?
I thought I had free stuff.
Wait, do I not have free stuff?
Oh, I have to check your storage box!
Oh!
Okay.
Yeah, I have to check my mail.
Okay, I'll come back.
Oh, is it DLC?
Okay, they should be in my chest.
Where's the map?
Is this my home?
Look at him!
He doesn't even wear pants!
I give you pants, Garfield.
Look at this.
Look at this cat.
He doesn't even have pants.
Look at him.
Look at Garfield.
You remember how well I treat you, Garfield.
The owner of this cat doesn't even give him pants.
Remember that.
I treat you so much better.
Okay, my yellow tent is right here.
Wait, where is my tent?
Where is it?
Look at him, Garfield!
Look at him!
You don't even give him... Look at his shirt!
I bet you that shirt was that owner's cat's shirt.
Look at him!
He also doesn't have pants!
Appreciate me!
Where is my house?
Wait, actually, where is my house?
Where do I live?
House of Garfield.
Right next to me?
I'm so confused of my living arrangements.
Wait, he can...
I lead the support team.
Look forward to working with you.
There should be more of us here, but we're running a bit behind because the others are running late.
I'm a bit worried.
Where the fuck do I live?
Did I walk past it?
I'm looking at my map and I don't know where it is.
Like, it says it's here.
But, like, where's the...
Is it this?
No, that can't be, right?
What is the quest icon?
This?
I don't know the maps in this game.
Tent near the entrance?
This?
Is this the entrance?
Next to the birds?
Oh, here?
This is my house.
Do I live here?
But, like, where's the storage?
Storage?
Where is it?
Oh, is this tent?
Is this where I live?
I can't even go inside.
It won't even let me go inside.
Oh my god.
I'm locked out.
I'm gonna have to talk to this guy.
Let me in my house.
Oh my god, this cat's naked!
Who the fuck let this cat... That's indecent exposure!
He's almost time for a meeting.
A meeting?
Yeah, and?
Who let this naked cat run around?
I don't know.
Toki is a cat police.
There is no laws against cat nakedness.
What unit am I?
Freak.
All the other cats wear clothes?
Who let this cat run around naked?
I succeed.
I just hate it when they can talk.
Let him be free.
Then we'll need to split up.
Make our search as wide as possible.
Good deal.
Except I think it'd be better if you held off until the support team arrives.
No objections here.
This project to survey the forbidden lands has been in the works for years.
And now here we are.
Finally.
Thank you all.
I'm sorry to cause so much trouble.
It's alright, lad.
We're in this together.
First things first, I think we ought to escort Nona and Isai back to their village.
For safety reasons.
That seems wise.
If we're lucky, someone there might have some information about the keepers.
Why don't we stop by our tent and prepare before we go?
Oh, I can finally go back to my tent.
Thank God.
Garfield isn't... Garfield isn't going commando.
What are you talking about?
This is not Garfield.
Alright, now I can go home.
Alright, let's see...
Get in my tent.
Oh my God, I have a tiny ass tent.
Alright, you and your pal go need to prepare for hunt.
Use your tent to change equipment, organize item pouch.
Okay, so I should be able to have...
Your trusted never leaves your side, but if you change your deployment sign, they'll go back to their tent and wait there until you're finished.
Can it go even while on standby?
Oh, so I can like not bring them.
But why would I do that?
Okay, but what if I do make him go naked?
Be free, Garfield.
Doki Beam, you do extra dash and thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What if he just wears a hat?
Alright.
Now we're talking.
Nice.
Alright.
Be free, Garfield.
Where's my items in here?
Jesus Christ, I am so overwhelmed looking at all this right now.
What do I have?
What are all of these?
What do I...
Wait, what is my...
What is my...
Okay, let's see.
Train mail.
I thought I had DLC stuff.
From the Kona cat?
Okay, let's see.
The Kona cat should have it.
Okay.
Where you can chat with friends, engage in multiplayer, online connection, you can invite other players.
Alright.
With... see the... with a fixed group of members.
You invite other players, be friends, be the lobby members, or hunt the ID search.
Okay, cool.
You want to change, you can set it, play with hunters, wildlife guys, whether you've joined a lobby or not, change which lobby you're currently in, talk to... and use the changed lobby.
Okay.
Oh, it's this one.
The one cat I talked to.
Where is that one?
Oh, this one, right?
And clear my DLC?
Salutation, Sanjay.
Welcome to the support desk.
We offer items supplied by guild, as well as important news you won't have to miss.
Tokyo's closed after taking his speech.
That was not my fault.
You guys wanted him naked.
Uhh...
Articress support?
Oh, there you go.
DLC.
Oh, wait.
I should claim it, right?
Since I already have my DLC.
Nice!
Okay, DLC, claim.
Claim.
Okay.
Mega potion, armor, spirit.
Wait, all of these are...
Wait, but they're all like...
Is that it?
I thought I had more.
Did I not have more?
Wait, should I...
That's it?
Oh!
I thought I had more.
Where my beautiful cat?
Alright, let's get the other armor for him.
Okay, uhh...
Let's give him the rest.
Yeah!
He looks ashamed.
Alright.
I mean, he looks happy that he's free now.
Free, not Garfield.
Hello.
Wait, can I actually get other hunters to help me?
How do I do that?
You're the most popular in the lobby.
A private lobby can only be joined by searching an ideal for those.
It's recommended for solo players.
This mode lets you pause the game from the start.
Oh, okay.
Alright, let's try it.
How do I... Did I do it?
How do I start my quest?
No?
I'm confused.
Uhh...
Am I in?
Did I do it?
I'm so confused.
Am I in?
I don't know.
Oh, I have login bonus.
Oh,
I'm in a private lobby by myself?
Oh shit, okay.
I wanna see other dragoons' cats.
Kyle, can I please have a game code?
You'll be my number one.
Who's number one?
Have they ever given you a game code?
Thank you for the super chat, Kyle.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Alright.
How do I find my...
How do I... Okay.
Lobby ID search?
How the fuck...
How do I know what my lobby ID is?
Does it tell me?
I don't even know what my lobby ID is.
The support desk?
Is it this one?
Oh, I have to make a lobby first.
Who are you Felicita?
Oh, okay.
Yeah, sure.
Kyle, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, I'll figure this out.
Okay.
Fuck.
Don't be bad.
There you go.
Wait, your cats have to be...
Okay, okay.
Your cats... Sorry, cat.
There we go.
Emblem icon.
Okay, we need a Palico.
Let's see.
Okay, is there an orange?
We need an orange.
I guess this is orange.
Is this orange?
Yeah, that's like Garfield.
Okay, emblem shape.
Okay, that's wrong.
Okay, there you go.
For those who are too many, please avoid content that is ILLEGAL OFFENSIVE.
Okay.
Hashtag.
Wait, what should I add?
Dragoon.
Reroll.
Naked, free the cats.
Okay, okay.
Dragoons, there we go.
There we go.
Squad created.
Your cats, there we go.
Nice.
Okay.
Now required, there we go.
This is my hashtag, free the cat.
Do I change that?
Yeah.
Hashtag, free, free the cats.
There you go.
That's my leader message.
Nice.
No talking cats.
Oh, you're right, you're right.
Your cat chat.
Hashtag, no talking cats.
There you go.
Nice.
It's just me.
This is like my, me and my one.
Wait, there's already 15 people in my squad?
Who the fuck is in my squad already?
Who are they?
There's already, there's already 15 people in, how is this, oh my god.
Holy fuck.
Okay, okay.
Damn, alright.
Nice.
Got my squad.
Okay, I gotta figure this out, guys.
Level 99.
Who's the, you're right, I'm gonna invite them.
I'm gonna invite the level 99 onto my team.
Let's get, let's get him in here.
How do I get him in here?
Madness squad.
There's 33?
Jesus Christ.
Every, see guys, these people.
Alright, view, view a pundit's profile.
Who is he?
What the fuck?
The fuck is that?
The unknown hero?
Who are you?
Who the fuck are you?
What?
Oh my god.
He's, bro, what's wrong with this cat?
Why is he wearing clothes?
Guys, I thought we said, I thought we agreed that your cats can't wear clothes.
Why is he wearing clothes right now?
Dude is on the grind.
That's a tab.
Cat has clothes, we gotta kick him.
Bro, how the fuck does, how, what the fuck?
What does he have?
Rarity 8, Rarity 8, Rarity.
The game just came out.
Oh my god, explain yourself.
Explain, what are these?
Level 52.
That's an endgame.
He's already in endgame territory.
What the feline gore ghost, eh?
The fuck does that even mean?
That's his paralysis demon.
Bro, you killed two things.
Wait.
Hunted 13?
He's hunted, excuse me?
He's hunted 10 of these?
Oh my god.
Bro, what do you mean?
What do you mean, give Rarity hunted 5 of them?
Oh my god.
That guy's freaking insane.
Bro, what the fuck?
Um, I actually reviewed, oh my god, you reviewed the, get in here.
Oh my god, he's a game reviewer.
How do I invite him to my squad?
Bro, I like how we all agree that we don't want, we don't want cats to wear clothes.
I'm glad we all agree.
I'm, I'm glad we all agree.
Wait, how do I?
Make your cat naked, right?
Strip, strip, free the cat.
Join the squad's lobby?
How do I do that?
Check squad, wait, how do I?
It's like a guild?
Oh, it's like a guild?
Okay, okay, I made my guild.
This is my dragoon guild.
Right there.
I made my dragoon guild.
Now I gotta figure out how to make a lobby.
Alright.
That's like level 99.
The fuck, what happened?
Alright.
Open, is it this?
Lobby search.
Conditional 100 friends squished.
Oh, squad lobby search.
There you go.
Oh, let's all join.
I'm joining the lobby.
This is it.
I'm in it now.
Alright, where's your cat?
Show me your, where's my cat?
Where's your cat?
Where is it?
Where are your cats?
Your cat's wearing clothes, I see him.
Virgil's wearing clothes.
Why is your cat wearing, that's right little Jimmy.
There we go, this guy knows the assignment.
Why is little Jimmy just sitting there?
Is he okay?
Is he?
Is little Jimmy okay?
He's just sitting there.
Bad toast for having clothes on.
Whose cat is this?
We gotta...
I need to know so I can kick them from the squad.
I need to know.
That's right, alright, there we go.
The silly little guy.
Little Jimmy.
Jimmy's just mad he has to be naked.
Where's the level 99 dev?
Level 99 game reviewer.
I need him in the squad right now.
I need the whatever the ghost cat is.
I need ghost cat right now.
No!
That's right.
Only cats with no clothes can join this squad.
Oh my god, look at this fucking tank.
He knows what he's got.
Look at Coco Bean.
Oh my god, Coco Bean is out there shredding.
How is this game dokey?
I did one mission and I've been stuck here.
He's a chuck.
Oh my god, look at all these cats.
Alright, nice, okay.
Now I gotta figure out how to create a... I'm still trying to figure out how to create a lobby, guys.
I'm still trying to figure out how to create a lobby.
Alright, I'm gonna figure this out.
We've been stuck... I'm still in the tutorial.
Okay, open.
Join quest.
Oh, okay.
You can access the quest counter.
What do I do?
Optional quest, assignments, event quest, lobby member quest.
Do I need lobby?
Okay, what do I do?
Wait, what is the settings?
Okay, it's four players.
Oh, that's the lobby?
Okay, assignment.
Oh, we already did that.
Is it optional quest?
Stage 12.
Is there any other quests here?
I mean, we already did this, though.
Oh, I have to do a story.
Oh.
Okay.
Just do the story?
Alright, guys, I'll be back, everybody.
I just gotta do the story now.
I gotta do the story.
Wait, you can customize your messages?
I didn't know that.
That's so cool.
How many people can I have in my guild, anyway?
How many people join my guild?
Wait, wait.
Wait a minute.
Wait a minute, I don't look at my chat.
Wait.
Why is your chat very close?
Oh my god, that's so good.
That's so good.
That's crazy.
That's such a crazy message.
Oh my god, that's crazy.
I love that.
I can't believe they let you do this.
Oh my god.
Oh, that's so good.
That's so good.
Holy fuck.
Wait, can we have 50 squads?
50 members in my squad?
Wait, really?
I can only have 50 members in my squad?
That's crazy.
Yeah, but I have a level 99 though.
Absolutely phenomenal.
That's such a good sticker.
Why is your chat way close?
Holy fuck, that's so good.
Oh, I can make more squads?
Okay, nice.
Let's head out.
I'll make another squad later.
This game is the future.
Alright,
after I do this next story...
Game of the year.
I'm so angry, John!
Goodbye everybody, I'm doing my mission now.
Goodbye.
Oh, that's so handy.
If I just do this.
Nice.
Oh, shoot the flare when the hunt starts?
Okay.
Oh, this is so convenient.
Is this new or has this always been in the game?
Oh, that's right.
I'm fucking catching the fireflies.
The fireflies are being endangered.
It's because of me.
Catching all of the fireflies.
Oh, that's new?
Yeah, this is so convenient, actually.
I love it.
I like how convenient that is.
Like, I don't have to actually walk up there.
The wiggly leechy.
I'm gonna kill that thing.
What is that?
Yeah, what is that?
Let's get closer.
Okay, Garfield.
It's definitely a nice feature.
What if I...
What if I just, you know...
Oh, I'm so tempted.
Alright, I just wanna...
I just wanna...
I just wanna kill it.
What if I...
What if I just poke them?
Can I not?
They're not aggressive.
See, look at them.
They're okay.
Wait a minute, what are you gonna do?
See, they're okay.
They're not gonna do anything.
Look at them.
Fucking cowards.
There I go.
Where's the other one?
Where's the other one I'm supposed to observe?
Get them.
These?
Am I supposed to observe?
Hello, guys.
See, look, they're okay.
I still have, like, something to observe.
But, like, I don't know what I'm supposed to.
Where are they?
What if I just...
Nah, I'm evil.
See, they're okay.
Look at them.
Goodbye.
There's, like, one more thing to observe, but where?
Oh, man, what a weird shape.
Huh.
Grab the stone, though.
What could I be observing?
Oh, well.
We're seeing nature.
Okay, but you guys know crows are pieces of shit?
That they actually do that in real life?
All they do is just annoy other animals and cause shit to happen?
Have you seen that video?
Like, there's a crow that starts a fight between, like, two dogs?
Want that honey?
I didn't find, like, the the optional quest.
There you go.
I got it.
Where do I follow?
Oh, this way.
Yeah, there's a video of, like, crows starting fights with other dogs.
Draw water?
Okay.
I want this.
Poke.
I want this, too.
I want all of this.
I want that wiggly litchy.
And I want this.
No, give it to me!
Yoink.
I'm just looting everything.
I want this, too.
And I want that honey.
I love the scattering tool.
It's literally a drive-by.
Give me that bug.
Wait, person.
Can I loot him?
Hello.
Hello?
Do I have to walk closer?
Oh, okay.
I did it.
That's me.
Okay.
What?
Pastor, try to find another route?
Why can't I come in?
Why not?
I'm just like them.
Is it because my cat's not wearing clothes?
Is that why?
Are you fucking oppressing my cat?
They said...
I think it's because my cat doesn't wear clothes.
I think they're jealous of my cat.
I can't believe it.
You're right, Garfield.
You're so right.
They're not carrying weapons.
You know what that means.
They're so vulnerable.
You're so right, Garfield.
They're so vulnerable right now.
Oh my god.
I can grab stuff from so far away.
That's crazy.
Oh shit!
Not the Felaci!
Felaci?
Don't worry.
I'm gonna kill them too.
Don't worry, I got them.
Don't worry, I'm helping you out.
Whoops.
Don't worry, guys.
Don't worry, I got you.
What the hell?
We're on death.
The collateral damage.
That's gonna happen anyway.
More loot for me, not gonna lie.
You're killing the victim.
More loot for me.
Nice.
It's not my fault they stood near me.
More loot!
Guys, more loot!
More loot, guys!
Oh my god.
More loot for me.
Yeah, I need them for- You missed them.
Did I?
Did I really miss?
I was helping out.
Yeah, but I have to pay with money.
Why pay when they're all just walking around?
Let's move.
Wait, no, wait.
I can't- I didn't fucking kill them for fun.
Wait, they all disappeared.
What the- Where are my kills?
What was the- No!
They all just disappeared!
No!
I'm armed!
Oh my god.
My population- Oh, there we go.
Nice, at least he stayed.
Oh shit, no, they all stayed.
No, they're all here.
Oh, I moved.
That's why.
I like moved.
Okay, I don't need the bugs.
I need these guys.
There we go, the female.
Look at that, see?
I get one herbivore shell.
Look at that.
Planned.
Let's just grab these guys.
Yeah, too much loot.
Exactly.
Guys, it wasn't the wrong target.
They were all the right targets, guys.
I don't like that they're still twitching.
Are these the arachnophobia monsters?
What would they look like if I, like, changed the- That's right, there's never a wrong target.
Nice.
I got raw meat.
You carve it more than once?
No, it's just once.
Oh, they get turned into slimes?
What do you mean wrong target?
There's literally- Oh, these are just flashfires, nevermind.
The big slime?
Oh, that's cool.
I want this.
Yeah, some kind of- You know what?
I want to know what you'd sound like when you start talking.
Okay, options.
How do I give you a voice?
Wait.
How do I give him a voice?
Can I do it here?
Talk to me.
Talk to me, little guy.
What do you sound like if I- Wait, what?
Oops, sorry.
Don't bully your cat.
I just want to know what he sounds like.
He's fine.
We're just playing around.
Right, Garfield?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Why do you sound like Deku?
He just sounds like- He sounds like the English dub of Deku.
Oh, we got it.
Oh my god.
This is so wrong.
You don't deserve rights anymore.
You are not allowed to talk.
Turn it off.
Talk to Jack?
Is that Jack?
Hey there.
What can I do for you?
It's not what God intended.
Disgusting.
Sweet deal.
Honey is the sticky secret to our healing potions.
You're literally a lifesaver.
This is for your trouble.
I receive the following as thank you.
Oh, I got a BBQ grill.
Fishing rod.
Binoculars.
Cat throwing knife.
Paint pot.
These are known tools.
You can use them as many as you like.
Click the play guide for details.
Yeah?
What is it?
Buy consumables such as- So these are just things I can buy.
I feel like I have a lot of these already.
Like, I don't have to worry about these yet.
Okay.
Oh, yeah?
Oh, I can upgrade?
Upgrade...
My bow, please.
Oh, wait.
It's a skill tree.
Okay.
I don't have any of these, though.
I guess I can upgrade.
Oh, that's interesting.
In the past, it wasn't a skill tree.
Okay, in the past, as in 2007.
On the PSP.
It was not a skill tree.
Sorry.
My history of the past.
Is 2007.
And in 2007.
There was no skill tree.
Sorry.
In the...
In the 1900s.
Alright.
We got that.
Do we have, like, more?
Okay.
Got an ore from mining.
When the dinosaurs roam the Earth.
When you can have multiple cats.
Alright.
Am I in my lobby?
Where are all the hunters?
Oh, yeah.
I was going to create a...
I was making these stickers.
There's so many.
Sorry.
Sorry, that's really good.
I'm not allowed to speak.
I don't have rights.
Oh, my god.
I'm sorry.
That was really good.
Okay, let's create another squad.
Squad number two.
Create new.
Squad settings.
Comment.
If your cat wear clothes, we kick.
There you go.
Emblem icon.
Okay, this one...
We'll do, like...
Okay, it still has to be...
It has to be a cat, but this time we'll make it...
We'll make it this orange.
Alright.
Emblem shape.
And then, put a cop there.
A cop emblem.
The badge.
Oh, wait, no.
Yeah, the shield.
Actually, we could do this, but...
Oh, we could have different colors.
We'll do silver.
Then we'll put the cat as this, but this time we'll have a different shield.
Okay.
Dragoon2.
Alright.
This is Dragoon2.
You weren't able to... Okay.
My leader message.
Hashtag.
Cats should not...
Should not...
Cats...
Should not talk.
Dragoon2.
Okay.
There we go.
That's my second squad.
There's already four people in here.
Nice.
Remember this.
We already have four people in here.
Dragoon2.
Cat.
No talk.
Alright.
Nice.
Do I have another mission?
Where's my, like...
Where do I have...
Where's the thing where the cats start making me food?
Check their cats.
I'll check their cats later.
I need them... I'm giving them time.
I'm giving them time to take clothes off their cats.
Hello.
Yeah.
Wait, I'm my own chef?
What's the point of having cats if they can't make me food?
Oh, an SOS flare.
Oh, shit.
Gotta go to the SOS flare.
I'm alive?
That was actually an accident.
Oh my god, I'm alive.
I don't know how the fuck I lived.
Oh my god, I lived.
What is fall damage?
Yeah, I thought about that too.
I was like, what the fuck?
How did I live?
Wait, I'm not.
Where's my health?
Granny's have perfect knees.
Wait, are these the chefs?
Oh my god, they're the chefs!
Thank god.
I knew I'd never...
Thank god I don't have to make my own food.
The only reason they're in danger is because they're wearing clothes.
Let's go!
It's because it's their job!
And they don't have the meat.
Then what is there use for?
Get on!
Hurry!
Are we allowed to?
We can talk about it later.
We have to follow them.
Follow them?
Follow.
Yeah, don't waste food, guys.
We'll meet up later.
Free the cat.
It's so weird.
All the other cats have clothes and then there's Garfield.
Be free.
Go, go,
go, go!
Oh my god, they have little mittens so their dirty cat paws won't infect the meat.
Is that a chicken?
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh my god, that was an accident!
I was trying to get...
I was like, what the fuck did I put down?
Actually, I did not mean to do that.
Yeah.
If it works, guys.
If it works.
It kinda works, yeah.
I mean, it worked.
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
Nice.
Oops.
I didn't mean to do that.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Wait.
I need...
Oh.
Nice.
Wait, oh, I can do this.
What the fuck?
How did you get in my lobby?
Wait, how did all of you guys get in my lobby?
Alright, nice.
Wait, you guys have...
Horses?
Or birds?
Where's Garfield?
No!
I forgot.
Wait, you can't use your cats?
Wait, you cannot use your cats?
It's like...
Oh wait, I have the charge.
Nice.
Oh my god, don't worry.
I'm doing it.
I'm so good at this.
Oh!
And there's people.
Oh, I see.
Okay, don't worry guys.
I'm doing my job.
My one damage.
Don't worry guys.
You are my Garfield now.
But this game is easy.
Pew!
Oh shit, guys!
I'm the bowman!
Nice.
Oh my god.
Pew!
This shot could end the war.
Easiest game of my life.
Look at that.
Pew!
Wait, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, I'm the bowman here.
Guys, why is he aggro to me, guys?
Okay.
Put them here because I accidentally put my barrel down.
Ow.
I can shoot my own barrel.
Nobody told me that.
Nobody told me I could shoot my own barrel.
Nobody told me.
Okay, I know now.
Guys, I now know I can shoot my own barrel.
Guys, I didn't know that!
Okay, what's a Paratone?
He's like limping.
I feel like he's almost dead.
Where's my little bird?
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Wait, guys, wait up!
Guys, wait up!
Nice.
Okay.
Watch this.
I feel like... Okay.
I'll shoot his knees.
Nice.
And then...
Pew!
Look at that.
Oh my God, that's so easy.
Easiest game of my life.
Yeah!
Oh, is cutting the tail good?
Where's the tail?
Is this?
Oh, wait, is this the tail?
Oh my God, free stuff!
I did it.
I cut the tail off, guys.
Guys, I did that.
Nice.
Oh, and I can grab this.
Guys, I did it.
Of course I'd get the rare drops.
I'm just that good.
Oh, wait, I should...
mine that.
I should mine that.
This is important.
Earth crystals.
Is there anything else?
A lily rose?
What the fuck is that?
Oh, it's a bone pile.
No!
My bone pile!
God damn it.
My fucking bone pile.
I can't believe it.
Look at that!
Number of focus.
Look at that.
Alan has nothing.
That means he did nothing.
Look at that.
Lily rose with the parts broken.
Me with the focus strikes on wounds.
Husky with the support all star.
What did Alan do?
What did he do?
That's right.
Oh, nice.
I do get my bones.
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
I got my bones before we headed back.
We do.
I can't walk.
Don't make me walk.
Yeah!
That's me talking about me.
Oh shit!
Oh, so I can bring my other weapon.
I like the bow so far.
Yeah, use the dual blades.
That bow gun and bow.
We do, bro.
Oh, by the way, everyone's been asking about you.
Me?
Oh my god!
I'm hunter rank number two now.
Okay.
Talk to Tom at the ingredients.
Talk to Ferdinand.
How many people are in my guild now?
Wait, I keep pressing right click instead.
17 people!
17!
Alright, I'm gonna check.
If you guys...
I swear, if your cats are wearing clothes, I'm gonna know.
I'm gonna know.
There we go.
That's good.
I'm glad we all know.
We all know.
I'm glad we're all on the same page, guys.
That's good.
I'm glad we're all on the same page, everybody.
What?
But you're here.
You're here.
You're literally here.
You have a cat that makes food!
Cook for me!
Tom!
I should've let that fucking monster eat you, Tom.
I should've fucking... Why does this cat have nose?
God damn.
I can make my own food?
Custom meals?
Recommended meals?
Prepare a meal.
Cook only with rations?
Does he cook for me?
What is this?
Health and stamina.
Okay.
I have to cook my own meal?
My cat's right here!
He's watching me!
Fucking Garfield.
Oh my god.
Garfield has to watch me cook?
He's all this fucking fat ass.
He's like, yep.
That's right.
What the fuck?
He's like, yep.
Lore accurate.
Cook that lasagna, Jon.
Lore accurate, Garfield.
Can't believe I have to cook.
I have to cook my own meals?
Oh my god.
I can't believe.
I was not expecting that.
Jon, I'm so hungry.
I need to talk to Nova.
I can't believe it.
I'm so sad.
Why are you holding up?
What's the point of owning cats if they don't cook my food?
They'll sing me a song.
Why won't they sing me a song?
Oh.
That's always sad.
Look, I'm still young at heart, guys.
I might have been born in the 1900's but I'm still young at heart.
Cook for yourself.
Fuck you, Alan.
You didn't get shit done during that fight.
You had no achievements in that fight.
Alright.
What do I do?
Who's this guy?
What the fuck?
Is he a person?
Wait, what is he?
Why does he look like that?
Oh, this is...
We killed all of these guys.
What's a wyverian?
Oh, is he an elf?
Do they...
What are they on the hierarchy?
Okay.
Are they like...
What kind of elves are they?
The top?
He's just like a guy.
Is he a cat?
No, it can't be.
Because he's wearing clothes.
It can't be.
They have clothes.
Alright, I'm checking your cats, guys.
I'm checking your cats.
Bring up the cats, everybody.
I swear.
Alright, whose cat is this?
Whose cat is this?
And why is he wearing clothes?
I like to report a cat with clothes.
It's cat inspection time.
Whose cat is this?
Who is it?
Whose fucking cat is this?
Is this your cat?
Miss Lily Rose?
Why is he wearing clothes?
One of you brought a clothed kitty and I'm gonna find out who it is.
It's inspection time.
This is a no clothes area.
Okay, talk to Alma.
Where the fuck are they?
Oh, they're over here.
Wait, I need to talk to Alma first.
Yeah, I do.
Uh...
Yo, tell me more about yourself.
Of course it's Alan's cat.
It's not a news call, Liam.
It's just the cats.
Nexi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh,
shit.
I shouldn't have asked the cats?
What?
Alright, let's see.
Can I join...
Do I have other quests yet?
Oh, I'm finished all of them.
Okay, settings.
I wanna do...
Okay, if I do two...
If I do two, does that mean like...
Uh...
I can have the cats fight for me as well?
I wanna have the cats fight for me too.
Or is it...
Is it only two max?
Two stays with... Oh, I want the cats to stay.
I want the cats to stay.
Alright.
Yeah, I'm ready.
Alright, let's head out.
I want...
I want Garfield to join me in my fight.
Yoink.
Take your wallet.
I don't know what to do with all of these.
I haven't used any of my items yet.
Capturing it.
Oh, shit.
Not what I wanted.
Shit.
What's this?
Where's my fucking hook?
Oh, okay, there we go.
Yoink.
I'm gonna hoard everything.
Honey!
Hello?
Can I be let in?
Oh my god.
They finally let my cat in.
Guys.
Look at that.
See?
Doesn't matter if you don't wear clothes.
You can still enter.
What the fuck?
Yeah.
They finally accepted him for who he is.
Oh.
So that's why it...
Wait, it doesn't work on the Palicos?
What's that on her back?
It's huge!
I guess they really haven't seen a weapon before.
Wait.
This is okay.
That guy is okay.
Oh, are these like the baby for...
Oh, they're like the babies for the little horses.
I'll tell my family to start getting everything ready for you.
Okay.
Be free, Garfield.
Be free!
Goddammit.
Oh, wait.
Guys, you can't...
Guys.
You can't take out your bow in this town.
I was gonna do one thing.
Talk to Elder...
Ella?
Talk to the woman tending to the fire?
Oh, this way.
Hello.
Hello, Granny.
Is that child okay?
Is that baby okay?
Why is his legs like that?
Oh,
it's my friend from high school.
Oh my god, it's been a while, Ella.
You look terrible.
Oh, wait, no.
Oh, you're right.
It's that kid I used to babysit.
Keepers?
Me?
Aww, you shouldn't have.
I know.
I go to the gym, bro.
How else am I gonna keep that six pack?
I just lift, bro.
No, she's talking about me, guys.
It's me.
She was talking about me, guys.
Where's the woman tending to the fire?
Oh, she's over here.
And moisturizer.
Moisturizer.
Milk drops?
What does it do?
I don't know.
I know.
Actually, yeah.
Did she follow us?
How did she know this place?
Like, did she fucking follow us?
It was like me, that guy, and like the other girl.
Hello, everybody!
Thanks.
Please, have a seat.
Thank you so much again for your warm hospitality.
It's the very least we can do.
Finally, somebody's gonna cook for me.
What the fuck is that?
Big beans?
It looks so tasty.
Is that pizza?
Pizza?
I was gonna say, am I in the UK right now?
Oh,
that looks good, though.
Yeah, that looks like nan.
That looks good.
I don't know about the big beans part, though.
Yeah, go Garfield, go.
Oh!
Is that mozzarella?
Oh, the cheese!
You know it's good cheese when that- oh my god.
That's good cheese.
Forgot about my pig tails.
That's right, you see these abs?
Those are granny abs right there.
That's how granny dookies taste, bitch.
We sighted a monster with long, thick fur near the village.
That sounds like a doshakuma.
They never used to venture out of the forest.
There's a forest?
There's a forest in Sandland?
Oh my god, we're going to Forestland!
We can never escape!
They attack our livestock, so we keep them panned up here.
We're going back to Forestland!
A bunch of ornaments make you feel safe?
Yes, you see, this region is home to a creature that even the doshakuma fear.
And it just so happens that the gem chimestones sound a lot like that monster.
And that's enough of a deterrent.
Interesting.
We played these games before!
I suppose we'll take our leave now.
Thank you for the wonderful food.
I don't need to know much about the sandstorm.
I don't care about nata, I'm sorry.
That's very kind, but we know how much preparing you have to do for the sandstorm.
Thanks for the grub!
Best I've had in ages!
That's fucking coarse, Garfield.
Thank you.
Let's start heading back to base camp.
I don't know, I just don't care about nata.
In this lore.
So, what's next?
Let's head to the forest.
Right, and maybe we should look into the doshakuma while we're at it.
But for today, let's rest.
We can start our investigation fresh tomorrow.
Alright.
Nata can ride with me.
How about we meet up on the path to the forest and go from there?
Alright, see you all tomorrow.
Alright, take care, Garfield.
We did it, Garfield!
We completed the quest!
I'm so good at this game.
Oh, I got a...
Oh, I got a new gesture!
Wait, how do I use gestures?
Nice, now he's...
Now he's naked.
Good.
Okay, before heading to the forest, try taking out some field surveys or optional quests to collect materials.
They'll be ready for everything.
Hunt more efficiently by joining your friends.
When it affects the meal you had or off, be sure to use another.
Okay, so we gotta cook.
Good.
As they should be.
Okay, we gotta...
Okay, I wanna get a...
Where's Alma?
Where is Alma?
Alma?
Where the fuck is Alma?
We did it, Garfield!
We successfully avoided responsibility.
Thank you for the super chat, NS.
Thank you, thank you.
Where the fuck is Alma?
By the tent?
That's not the...
Oh wait, that's her.
Whoops.
I couldn't realize that was her.
Okay, post-join quest.
Where's my optional ones?
My optional ones are already done, though.
Do I have to hunt them again?
Wait, can I... Oh!
I can hunt them again!
I see.
Alright.
Let's do this again.
What's the lucky voucher?
Okay, accept and prep.
Oh!
Alright, guys.
I need one other member.
One brave soul to help me hunt this guy.
I like how everybody starts surrounding Alma.
Me!
BigBang!
Urb was the lucky guy.
I like how everybody's surrounded her.
He's like, Me!
Me!
How do I...
How do I... Oh, you know.
The part now.
Oh, wait!
I forgot to check the cat.
Oh, you're right.
Cat inspection.
Oh, fuck.
I forgot.
Alright, next time, I'm checking your cat.
I swear to god.
Okay, there you go.
Alright, Coco Bean.
There you go.
That's good.
Coco Bean is fully unclothed.
That's how we like it here.
Grab some herbs.
Wait, where is he?
Where's the...
Oh!
There's no fall damage.
I can literally do that.
Alright, let's go!
If I hook at boulders to make the... Wait, you can do that?
How do you do that?
Like this?
Oh!
Wait, that's so cool!
I don't know we can do that.
Wait, there he is!
There he is!
Wait, what's Alma doing here?
Hello?
Alma?
What's Alma doing here?
Yeah, but why is she here?
Alright!
Go do your thing!
Herb!
Shoot him!
Oh!
You can cancel your quest!
Wait, where's Herb?
Wait, where is he?
Wait, where the fuck is he?
Wait, where did he go?
Where did Herb go?
Where did...
Oh shit!
There he is!
Oh!
Sorry!
I didn't realize you were fighting him already.
Alright, don't worry Herb, I'm right here.
I'm helping.
Don't worry.
Agro him!
Agro him, Herb!
Do your thing!
Sorry I missed, but do your thing!
Don't worry, I got you!
I missed, but I got you!
Do your thing!
God, oh god, oh god!
Perfect dodge!
Nice!
Hey, I'm okay though, Herb.
That's all that matters.
Herb, keep doing your thing!
Good, Herb!
Oh shit!
Nice!
Don't worry, I'm doing it!
Garfield's doing it too!
Okay, okay!
Okay, we can't have him get close to me!
Herb, you're supposed to aggro him, Herb!
Herb!
Herb, you're supposed to...
You're supposed to aggro him!
What are you doing?
Nice!
Okay, nice!
I got this!
I'm just gonna keep doing this.
If you keep aggroing him, I can do this!
All day!
Oh, never mind!
Okay!
God, I'm so good at video games!
Woo!
Okay, I have my stamina.
He needs to rebuild though.
Herb, Herb, Herb!
What is he doing?!
Get out of here!
Oh wait, he has wounds!
Nice!
I got the wound!
Shut the fuck up, Alma!
I'm fucking fighting him!
Alright, let's go!
Alma, I have important things to do!
Okay.
Uh...
Yeah.
Nice, I got it!
Oh, no!
He touched me.
My perfect score.
Why, Root?
Because I'm trying to fucking fight!
You don't just interrupt the fucking fight!
Oh my god, why are you looking at me?!
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Oh, okay, I did that.
Okay, nice.
Woo!
Watch this.
Oh my god, 24?!
That's me!
Okay, nice.
Nice.
Oh!
Oh,
shit.
Some say I'm a gamer!
Oh my god, another perfect dodge!
Look at that!
Yeah, I'm gonna...
Woo!
Nice.
Now do another fire.
He has no wounds, though.
Oh, wait, no, he does!
Oh, he's, like, limping, so I can't...
Okay, I need to carve this real fast.
Okay, um...
That guy's a bad guy, right?
It'll be fine.
I'm gonna carve this, though.
Alright, I'm heading over.
Alright.
Oh, he's gonna sleep!
He's gonna sleep!
Wait, are they gonna fight each other?
If they fight each other, do I get the win?
On the quest?
Oh, wait, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Wait, wait, wait!
Nice.
That's how I like it.
Oh, they do?!
Oh, I didn't kill him.
I thought I did.
Pew!
Oh, shit.
Nice.
Okay.
Got it.
Nice.
I got the winning blow!
Yeah!
Nice.
I got the winning blow, guys.
I did that.
That's right.
I carried her.
I carried.
I'm so good with a bow, guys.
Wait, the bow is actually so fucking easy.
I'm not gonna lie.
The bow is actually so easy.
I don't know.
I didn't know weapon is pretty easy.
I do it a lot!
What do you mean?!
The first...
The first monster I hunted...
I did it with a bow alone.
Solo the entire game.
I just wanna help my fellow dragoons, guys.
I was just helping them out.
Guys, guys.
I just feel so bad for my dragoons.
I don't know.
I just felt like a good heart to help them out.
Let them have an easier time.
Look at that.
I broke two parts, guys.
That was me.
I did that.
Wait, there's more combos?
Other than dragon...
That's all I've been doing.
I've just been doing dragon piercer.
I was like, wait.
There's more?
There's more to life than dragon piercer?
Let's put the dual blades.
How do I swap my weapons, though?
Okay.
Hope daggers.
But how do I swap it?
I wanna swap my...
Oh, X on the mount.
Okay.
Alma.
Oh, I have to do it on the bird.
Oh, okay.
Okay, so I did the optional quest.
I think we progressed it now.
I feel like we don't need to worry about anything else.
Let's see if there's anything I can upgrade.
Will you dress dad in a hot dog?
I actually have a hot dog costume.
I bought it for his second Halloween.
I bought a hot dog costume.
Do I have upgrades for it?
No.
I don't know what to find.
Can I upgrade my armor?
Oh, I can.
I need the...
Is this the one I killed?
Is it stronger?
No, it's the same.
Oh no, this is stronger.
Okay.
I like this more.
I have enough for this.
Wait, I do have this too.
But they're weaker though.
Yeah, all of these are weaker.
I'll get this first.
Yeah, equip it.
Wait, what are the shoes?
I need this more.
Nice.
Do I have any of my upgrades yet?
Oh no, not like bowgun.
Bow.
The bone...
Oh, I do!
I have the bone tree.
Wait, the attack is better.
I have the bone.
Wait, attack...
130.
Thanks for the carry, Doki.
Yeah, I don't know how I did it.
I don't know how I did it.
But that was pretty cool.
Oh, is this a fire bow?
Is it this?
Is this a fire bow?
Okay, let's try it.
I want to try the fire.
Oh, look at that.
That's my bow.
Okay, I'll get the primary for this.
Oh, now I know.
Now I know why you guys were like...
Use two bows.
Oh, that makes so much more sense now.
I was confused.
I was like, what the fuck do you mean, use two bows?
I was like, what the fuck do you mean?
Should I use normal daggers or fire?
You know I fucking fire daggers.
Or should I do normal?
Just in case, like...
I don't know.
We'll do fire daggers for now.
Because I have enough equipment materials for it.
Alright, next fight we'll use daggers.
Secondary, okay.
Oh shit, you're right, I should give him...
Let me see if I can...
I forgot to see if I have a pal...
Goddammit!
Sorry, Palico.
I forgot about you.
Oh, sorry, I already used all my...
I already used all my items.
Oh, so that's how he has all these.
Wait, is this stronger?
Is this stronger?
That's the same.
I don't know what range though.
Severing?
Nah.
You're keeping the hammer.
It's alright.
Why does this cat have clothes?
Loki?
I know that cat's your cat.
I know that's your cat.
Why does he have clothes?
Why does your cat have clothes?
Huh?
I know he's your cat.
Don't pretend I don't know.
Take his clothes off right now.
Go to the tent.
Go to the tent and take his clothes off right now.
Go to the tent and take your cat's clothes off right now.
I'll wait here.
I'm gonna wait here.
I can wait.
Guys, we have one rule in this guild, guys.
We have one single rule.
Your cat must not wear clothes.
I literally have one rule to join this guild.
Shame.
That's right.
Good!
Oh my god, he's so naked.
Oh my god, look at him.
He's just... he's just bare.
That's good.
That's how we like it here in this guild.
That's how we like it here.
Oh shit, I keep pressing right click and I don't know why.
I wanna see my other guild.
I like how Dragoon 2 just only has 19.
Everybody wants to be in the Dragoons 1.
Alright.
All I'm saying is that...
Is that if I see any cat with clothes in Dragoons, I'm demoting you to Dragoon 2.
Just know, just know that if I see clothes on...
What the fuck you already...
If I see clothes on your Dragoon squad, you're getting demoted to Dragoon 2.
Wait.
Alright.
Let's pick a random goon.
Okay, Codeman.
Oh, Codeman.
Codeman.
Guess who's getting demoted.
Is that a shirt and hat I see?
Oh, that's a shirt and hat.
Cut.
Alright.
Alright, Codeman.
Time to join Dragoons 2.
And before he's not even watching, he's just like, wait, why did I get kicked out?
That's right.
No hats.
I think that's just a hunter card.
No, because if I look...
If I look at my...
Wait, how do I look at my own profile?
Okay, if I look at...
Okay, I know one person doesn't have clothes on.
Who is it?
It was...
Okay, Lily Rose doesn't have clothes on.
I know that.
Look, see?
Look at that.
Lily Rose knows the assignment.
Give him a second chance.
Alright.
Codeman.
Oh, Codeman.
Yeah?
You're still here, Codeman.
Did you take off the clothes off?
He's like, no.
No, don't.
Don't, please.
Let me stay.
Let me stay, please.
Alright, where's your cat?
Is it Canoli?
Did you strip your cat?
Alright.
Let's check.
Let's check in Codeman.
Don't kick me out, please.
I'll not strip.
I'll take his clothes off.
Alright.
Let's see.
Codeman!
Your cat is still wearing clothes, Codeman!
Codeman.
Canoli, my...
Wait, can you actually change your profile?
Wait, how do you change your, like...
Wait, is it cause, like, your Hunter profile?
Hunter profile.
Yeah, see?
He's not wearing clothes.
Oh, his card not updated.
Alright.
I saw Canoli.
You know what, Codeman?
You got...
Canoli was saved today, Codeman.
Because you showed me your cat.
Okay.
Okay, let's check.
He's like, please.
This is my life now.
I know you made the squad two hours ago, but this is my life.
Please.
I'm here to help anytime.
Please don't kick me out.
Look how happy he is!
He's so happy.
Look at that.
See, Canoli is so much happier.
He even removed his hat.
You guys are lucky.
Oh my god, there he is!
There he is!
That's level 100!
Oh my god, it's him!
It's the legendary level 100 Hunter break!
Where's his naked cat?
Which one is his cat?
I don't know which one it is.
He had a fucking ghost as a cat.
It's him!
The legendary level fucking 100!
Okay, head towards the forest.
How the fuck?
Where is the forest?
Oh, it's this way.
How do I go to the forest?
Wait.
Am I going the right way?
I don't know where the forest is.
Guys, where's the forest?
Is it this way?
Where is the forest?
Oh, auto move?
Am I auto move right now?
I can't tell.
Wait.
How do I do auto move?
Am I auto moving?
There's a map.
Where the fuck is the forest?
Is this the riverside trail?
What the fuck am I looking at?
I don't know where I'm going.
Oh, it's right here.
Okay.
Okay, go.
Take me to the forest.
Okay, I think I'm heading...
Yeah, I'm heading to the forest.
Alright, go.
Look, I'm just very confused.
Woah.
Wait, I can't go across.
Where do I go across?
Am I going the...
What?
I'm so confused, Alma.
Why is my auto...
My auto thing isn't working.
How's my auto movement not working?
Is this the forest?
Oh, I have to mark it?
Oh my god, I thought it just does it.
Okay, give me a sec.
I'm very confused.
Okay, where's the forest?
Oh.
Okay.
Is this...
Are you in the forest?
Oh, that's the forest?
Oh, okay.
Alright, go.
Now it should auto.
I figured it out, guys.
I figured out how to use the auto.
I was so confused.
I was like...
I thought it would just automatically auto for me.
Okay.
Not gonna wait?
What the fuck?
I bet the forest is so big.
It's got trees coming out of trees.
Okay, Garfiel.
Trees coming out of trees.
Alright, I figured it out, guys.
I'm so smart.
Forest findings.
Oh my god, we're finally at chapter one.
I know!
I wish we could ride the dogs!
Now we have, like, birds.
Because you can customize your dog, right?
In the last game.
Noink.
I would've made dad.
I thought we'd get dogs.
That's why I, like, made Garfield.
That's the only reason why I made Garfield.
Because I was like, well, I would get a dog too, so I...
Oh my god, we're finally in forest land.
We made it, guys!
Yoink.
I love this mechanic.
It's so fun.
It makes looting so easy.
Oh my god, it's just like Sand Land.
Forest land is literally right next door.
Surprisingly, the game runs really well.
I honestly thought it was gonna, like...
Like my, you know, I was gonna lag and everything.
But it's actually running so well.
That's where all the water went.
The water is red?
The fuck?
Yeah, what's wrong with the water?
Oh, we set up a new camp.
Are we not going back to Sand Land?
Is this my new home now?
Because that's what a forest is.
I knew you'd show up.
I'm glad we didn't disappoint.
We'll give you a hand.
So,
Captain, what's your team been getting up to?
Please, call me Olivia.
Oh my god, oh!
First name, faces!
Wow!
Olivia!
Wait,
he?
I'm saved!
So you've heard of him too?
He's one of the big brains behind the Wyvern's fire technology.
Wait, what?
We are so gonna talk later, pal!
Oh my god!
It's like more beautiful than some of the others!
Monsters called the Doshagama have left their...
What's your skincare?
As a biologist?
What the fuck is your...
Oh, I guess because he goes outside a lot, so his skin must be more moisturized than the others.
I was gonna be like, the fuck is your skincare?
Smash.
Bro,
look at those lips!
Like, what's your fucking treatment?
He uses biology as skincare.
I was like, bro, man!
What's your routine?
Chop that skincare routine, yeah!
Wait, what?
I like to request support?
Oh, request?
Oh, I don't have any.
Oh, do I have this?
Oh!
Okay.
Did I get this?
Oh no, I didn't.
He rubs the bugs on it.
Oh, did I talk to Nata?
I don't like talking to Nata.
Like, I don't really care too much about Nata.
I don't think you've been helpful at all, Nata.
What?
Wait, you're right.
Why are you here?
What?
Wait, what's the point of talking to him?
Oh, I guess for lore reasons, I guess.
Oh, that makes sense.
I was like, why don't I talk to him?
Okay, let's see.
Okay, talk to Eric.
Alright, Eric.
I gotta talk to you now.
Sorry.
Yeah, let's head out.
Thank you.
I was starting to worry that we'd have to sprout wings to keep up.
Shall we depart?
Alright, nice.
Wait, the campsite?
Oh, is there a new campsite?
Oh!
Okay.
Where's my...
Do I not get to ride my...
Oh, I don't.
I have to walk like a fucking caveman.
Can't believe it.
I have to walk to my new campsite?
What's the point of having a fucking horse?
How uncivilized.
Wait, what?
Oh.
Guess I'm not allowed to go there.
But like, it says this way.
That blue mushroom.
Oh, I've never seen that bigger wasp before.
Oh, it's just...
I just killed a toad?
Oh, it's like a stun!
I killed him just for fun.
Where are these?
Where are you?
That's right.
I did it for fun.
Oh wait, they might actually kill me.
There you go.
That's right!
I want your meat!
That's fucking right!
Give me your meat!
Oh shit, wait.
Wait, I'm stuck, I'm stuck, I'm stuck!
Oh no!
Oh no, it's considering me wandering!
Okay, what do I get from this?
Oh, a fin!
Okay, let me get these guys out of the way.
That's right.
Get out of here!
Time to carve!
What do I get?
Sharp fang.
Oh, a fin.
Alright, let's go.
Sorry, intermission.
We're ready to go now.
Ooh, fire herb.
That was very important, guys.
Smoke nut.
I feel like I'm gonna have to kill something soon.
Wait, you're right.
It's not red.
Yeah, why is it red?
I'm gonna kill the baby.
He's still alive!
Nice.
Wait, I can't even carve the baby.
What was the point?
Oh no, I can.
Nice.
Look at that.
Their parents ran.
Didn't even protect their child.
What do you mean, water herb?
It's right here!
Oh, I have to wait for the...
Finally, a game for me.
And now I know why people love Monster Hunter.
Alright.
S.O.S.
I killed a child, so I need help covering up a murder.
If you join my squad, you're only enabling me.
Alright.
As a fash, I can use as a report point.
Return.
Okay.
We should look for any tracks or traces.
If you join my squad, you're an accomplice to murder.
And you agree with my message.
Alright.
If anybody is gonna update my...
VTuber...
What was it?
VTuber Wikipedia?
Make sure to put that was born in 1900s.
That's very important, guys.
New lore drop.
And then the footnote can be the beginning of the stream.
Where it was like, put your date of birth.
And then I literally put...
That was born in 1900s.
Update that wiki right now.
Is your oshi a true hag?
Nice.
Take that.
Oh, shed fur?
Who's shedding?
Oh, Shaxx, I skipped it cause I was pressing F.
Oh, the dog, Shaguma.
Show me!
Thank you for the...
Thank you for the gifted ships!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh, there's more fur.
Nice.
What's this?
Yeah, what is that?
What's over there?
Wait, that's not Doshaguma.
What's that?
The scat flies seem to be reacting to something deeper in.
Oh, shit.
Is it bigger?
Oh, is it why it's red?
Is it blood?
My word.
Is this a lalabarina, Floret?
A lalabarina?
What's a lalabarina?
It's a monster.
A temnocerin.
Smell.
Oh, like the Doguma got killed?
Is that why it's red?
And you made her smell it?
Breathe the poison deep.
Yeah, keep breathing in that poison.
Maybe that's how his skin looks so nice.
Is Rayden missing?
How?
He walked like 5 feet!
Like he walked 5 feet!
Why?
How did he wander off alone in 5 seconds?
How do you lose him that fast?
It's like 5 seconds.
What the fuck?
5 seconds!
5 fucking seconds!
Oh, does he turn into a slime?
What if I just left him to die?
Oh, I guess not.
Like, is he really that useful?
He's a biologist.
I'm sorry for all the biology majors out there.
I'm sorry to all the biologists out there.
My job is to hunt.
Oh shit.
It's to hunt, not to study.
If you think about it.
Okay.
Oh!
Like, I can't even tell if he's supposed to be doing damage to me!
Wow!
Okay, I need to make sure I don't get out of here.
Man, I wanted to use my dual blades, but I can't.
What?
Wait, what?
How did I get hurt?
Phew!
Wait, is he blind?
What is he looking at?
Is it Garfield?
Is he looking at Garfield right now?
Phew!
Oh nice, I got it.
Nice.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Oh no.
Oh no!
I think I got weapons off of him.
Oh!
Oh shit!
Wait, I have my- my dog?
Wait, I do!
Where is he?
Wait, I want to swap weapons.
Nice, it's dual blading time!
That's right!
Wait, oh he's gone.
Okay, nevermind.
That's right, it's dual blading time!
Oh my god, it's the legend himself!
It's him!
He's here!
Oh my god, it's level 100, man!
Oh my god!
Why is he faster?
Do you just- are you just faster with level 100?
Like- Like, don't worry!
Demon Mode!
That's right!
Get over here!
That's fucking right!
I don't know what I'm doing, I'm just slashing!
Demon Mode!
I'm just slashing!
Demon Mode done!
Nice!
It's just that easy!
Classic dual blade gameplay!
That's right!
The hero of Demon Dual Blades in a nutshell!
Get over here!
Demon Mode!
Woo!
Alright!
Nice!
Oh wait, there he is!
Okay, but this guy is more important!
I'm coming for you!
That's fucking right!
You think you can run?
Demon Mode!
Jesus Christ!
This is my entire gameplay!
Do you think I care?!
Oh my god, all I do is slash!
I don't care!
I don't know what I'm doing, I'm just slashing!
Okay, Demon Mode down!
Demon Mode down!
Demon Mode back on it!
Woo!
So easy!
Oh my god!
Ground Slash!
Blade Dance!
Oh my god!
Woo!
That's how you dual blade!
It's okay.
That's how you do it.
Okay.
Let's get that carcass in.
I don't know what the fuck happened, but I slashed!
Oh, there's a- didn't I break a piece of him off?
I thought I did.
Did I not?
I thought I broke a piece of him.
Are my legs dull?
I can't tell.
Okay.
Where's my sharpener?
Oh, there it is.
There we go.
It's okay now.
It's okay, I fixed it.
Oh, someone else grabbed it.
Oh wait, do I pick it up automatically?
I don't know.
I can't tell.
I did it!
I killed Lala Barina.
Nice.
Oh nice, my Palico leveled up too.
Oh shit.
Guys, look.
Guys, look!
He's level not 100, okay?
Of course.
Of course he achieves.
Okay, maybe like...
Dual Blades is not for me, guys.
Maybe...
Maybe the bow is cooler.
Look, he's level 100, guys.
How am I supposed to match up to a level 100 guy?
A poison?
Are we not gonna fix him?
We're just gonna ignore the fact that he's poisoned right now?
Thanks for giving Conrad and I a chance to conform before demoting us to Dragoon 2.
Loki, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No, not Dragoon 2.
I don't want to sit here.
I want to help.
Thank you.
I'm grateful for your help.
We'll be counting on you.
Anything but that.
Don't put me down there.
Thanks.
Okay.
Oh my, we did it.
Oh, does that mean we have like...
Okay, we might have new stuff to...
Hunter, can I borrow you a sec?
Oh shit.
Yeah.
Yeah?
Hey, have you been upgrading your weapons?
And don't give me that.
I'm a good guild leader, guys.
Nonsense.
You want your gear to be effective, right?
Here, I'm giving you some materials, so no excuses.
Oh, nice!
Free stuff!
I love free stuff.
Okay, we got Earth Crystals.
What can we upgrade?
The weapon tree...
Shows wild forge items.
An upgrade list shows what you're currently...
Oh, okay.
Oh shit!
Okay.
So I can grab...
Oh, this is a new one that I can have.
It's 144.
I don't know.
Do I try...
I guess I could.
I'll think about it.
I don't know.
I'll save it for now.
I feel like I should save it for now.
Where is...
Where is my guild?
Where's my guild thing?
I need to know.
Wait, I can fish!
My senses are my fish and my shaman.
The day I play...
I suppose I should introduce myself.
It's a pleasure.
Wait, can I fish?
How do I fish?
I wanna fish.
Where's my fishy?
Is no fish gonna bite?
Wait, is it like...
Oh, I have to aim it at this guy.
Okay.
Bite my...
Oh shit, okay.
Bite it.
Wait, what?
What?
What the fuck?
Get my fish!
I swear to God, if you guys take my fish...
I swear to God, I don't know what I'm doing.
What the fuck?
One of us will get that fish.
This is not fair.
I want that one fish.
Oh my God, please!
Why can't I fish?
Wait, why does it do that?
Why does it like auto-reel?
Yeah.
This is bullshit.
This is actually bullshit.
I don't know what I'm doing, I'm sad.
Getting fish!
Why is your cat allowed to fish?
Why can't my cat fish?
Garfield, fish right now!
Garfield, fish!
Why is my fish not working?
Why can't my cat fish?
What's wrong with him?
What the fuck is wrong with him?
This is not fair.
My cat can't fish.
Come on, come on, come on, right here, right here, come on.
Fucking...
Why does the... I give up.
I fucking give up, I cat fish.
I don't... wait, wait, no, I can do this.
I can get this one fish.
I can do it.
Come on.
Come on!
How does it work?
How does this... why is everybody else getting fish?
How does this work?
Somebody...
Come on.
It's right here.
Get over here.
Come on.
Right over here, right over here.
Come on, I see you.
Whoa.
Whoa, I see you.
Who caught that?
Right here.
Whoa.
Guys, guys, right here.
Guys, right here.
No, no, no.
Right here.
Guys, it's right here.
Guys!
Give me my fish!
I'm so sad.
Why won't fish bite?
Why fish don't want food?
I don't understand.
How fish?
I give up.
You guys, I give up.
Fish won today.
Fish...
I...
I don't...
Why is your cat wearing clothes?
Momiji?
Why is it wearing clothes?
Oh.
Oh, she's AFK?
Okay.
Alright.
Just cause you're AFK...
That is unfortunate.
You know what?
You're saved by your Dragoon buddies.
Just cause you're AFK.
You're lucky.
You're so lucky.
Alright.
It's time to check...
Where's Alma?
Alma!
Oh, Alma!
It's time to check...
Oh, wait.
Not Alma.
Where's the guild people?
Okay.
There's Gemini.
There's...
Wait.
Where's the guild woman?
Is the guild woman not here?
I guess she's not.
Okay.
You guys are lucky.
I can't...
I can't double check on you guys.
I can't check on my guild here.
Alright.
I...
Oh my god.
I've been streaming for four...
Okay.
I'm gonna call it here.
Cause...
I...
I can't fuck up my voice.
But!
We're not ending yet!
Because...
We still have our giveaway!
So let me set that up right now.
Yeah.
It's actually been four hours.
That's actually crazy.
So let me set up my giveaway now.
Alright!
So I think I still have my text from the last giveaway.
Do I?
Wait.
I do.
Okay.
Alright.
Where is my cat?
Where's Garfield?
And where did my cat go?
Guys, where did my cat go?
Garfield?
Garfield!
Garfield, where are you?
Where did Garfield go?
Garfield!
Oh, there you are.
Garfield, what the fuck are you doing?
Get up.
Garfield.
Get up here.
Get over here, Garfield.
Why are you...
Garfield, get over here.
That's right.
Okay.
Alright!
So!
It is giveaway time!
Before we go!
That was really fun though.
I actually had a great time.
Uh...
That was actually really fun.
I...
For my very first Monster Hunter game.
I actually had a lot of fun playing this game.
Um...
And I...
I hope you guys too.
Yeah, too.
I hope you guys enjoyed watching me trying to play...
Uh...
Trying to play Monster Hunter for the first time.
Ever since 2007.
Alright!
So!
To enter the giveaway...
Let me...
Alright.
So...
Let me do the text real quick.
Alright.
To enter the giveaway...
Hashtag...
Extra...
Extra point...
Enter...
Uh...
To join...
The give...
The giveaway...
For...
Monster...
Hunter...
Code...
Wait.
What did I put last time?
Okay, guys.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna swap real quick.
Because I just want to copy this.
Okay.
There we go.
Enter for monster...
Okay.
It's this one.
It's text 10222.
Okay.
We're gonna move back to the other one.
Only use it once.
Because if you do it more than once, it actually removes your entry.
So, like, make sure you don't do multiple times.
I think if you spam it, it removes it.
So, yeah.
Just make sure you don't do it multiple times.
And you'll be fine.
Alright.
Here you go.
Enter for monster...
If you win, give us your app for your Twitter or Twitch account.
And we have five codes.
Alright, guys.
I'm gonna give, like...
I'm gonna give, like, 10 seconds.
So, make sure you don't spam enter.
Because it will remove your entry if you do spam enter.
It's exclamation point, enter.
And you should be fine.
Is it case sensitive?
That's a good question.
Let me check real quick.
It's capital letter E.
I don't know if it's case sensitive, guys.
But just to be sure, it's capital E.
Just as it's written over here.
So, like...
I'm not sure if it is case sensitive.
But, like, I'm not gonna...
I don't wanna risk it.
Look at all of them clapping for it.
Clapping for the giveaway.
Like, yeah, giveaway!
Yeah!
Alright, I'm gonna do a countdown.
And I'll pull the first winner.
Five, four...
Again, thank you to MSI for sponsoring today's stream.
My mods have been, like, using the commands regarding the special collaboration that MSI is doing.
MSI is providing these game codes for me.
So, huge shoutout to MSI for the sponsor.
Alright, five, four, three, two, one.
I'm pulling the first winner.
Suchan WS!
Congratulations!
Congratulations on being the first winner.
We need you to type a reply I have on my nightbot.
It does show me your messages when you do type in it.
So, yeah, let me know if you're live and you can see yourself.
I need to know if you're live.
If you don't respond within 30 seconds, I will have to, unfortunately, pull...
I will pull another...
Not 30 seconds, I'll do, like, 40, 50 seconds.
Just to be, like, you know...
You know, just to give you guys time.
But, you have not typed anything yet, so I am a little worried.
Let me do the add to Suchan.
Alright.
Best, congratulations!
If you can provide us your Twitter ad or your Twitch ad, just let us know.
Our Twitch is Suchan.
Alright, congratulations!
My mods will be providing you guys the codes and everything.
So, just make sure to check your whispers.
Check your whispers.
Check your DMs.
And make sure your DMs are open for Twitter.
Because my mods will be providing the codes.
Alright, next winner!
The next winner is...
But, you guys can enter even after we draw winners, too.
So, don't worry about, like...
Oh, no, I was too late to enter.
Next winner!
OZERO!
Congratulations!
Congratulations, OZERO!
For winning the second game code!
Yeah!
Like I said, we just need your ad for your Twitter and Twitch.
So, the second code is 1byOZERO.
Congratulations!
Yeah!
And then, you can join...
Alright, remember...
I hope my mods are writing this down.
I hope...
I hope they're writing down the winners.
Alright.
Oh, that was fast.
We already got straight away the ad.
Congratulations!
The second code.
Alright, third code.
We're going by super fast.
Because I also...
I need to walk Doki Amber Doge after this.
I didn't think I'd be streaming for four hours.
But, like, I actually got, like...
Sunked in.
With Monster Hunter.
Patchesaur!
Congratu...
And also, like, my voice is fucking dying.
Patchesaur!
Congratulations, Patchesaur!
Congratulations!
Yeah, that's our third code!
Woo!
As always...
See, guys?
I told you we guys got better at this.
I told you guys.
Yeah, the last...
You know, when we did the pre...
When we did the pre-giveaway codes...
Like, before the stream...
It was pretty bad.
I would admit.
It was pretty fucking bad.
We were all over the place.
But now, look at us go.
We are so professional now.
We did it.
We figured it out.
It only took one stream.
It only took one stream of a failed attempt.
But now, we're doing good.
Now...
Now, it's like...
Bam, bam, bam.
So professional.
Congratulations, Patchesaur!
This is my third one?
Oh, shit.
Okay, wait.
One...
Guys...
Okay, guys.
One...
Two...
Sorry.
One...
Oh, shit.
Give me a sec.
One...
Two...
Three.
Okay, we're at the third.
Okay, this is the...
Next one is the fourth.
The next one is the fourth, guys.
We got this, everybody.
Sorry, I had to...
I lost count.
We're still professional.
The next winner is...
Behind...
What was it?
Oh, shit.
I pulled two.
Guys, we just pulled two at the same time.
Whoops.
Sorry, I...
Okay, this is a little more...
Okay, now we're getting into the scuffed territory.
But we pulled two.
Yay!
That's four and five.
We did it!
We're so professional.
Oh, I actually...
I double-clicked, guys.
I double-clicked.
Very professional.
But congratulations, Behindjul and ZealousNeko.
Remember to give your Twitter at or your Twitch at.
And then, that should be it.
But I'm gonna wait until Behindjul and...
Okay, I can't see Neko.
So, like, I hope that my mods will be okay in trying to find them.
Oh.
Okay, we got Neko.
Behindjul, if you are alive, we need to know.
You have...
You have 15 seconds to claim your code.
Behindjul?
Behindjul, where are you?
No!
Okay, I'll give him, like, 10 more.
Wake up!
Wake up, Behindjul!
He hasn't even said hi.
Guys, we might actually have to do another claim.
Okay, I'll give him, like, 5 more seconds.
Wake up, Behindjul!
You got the...
Wake up!
Guys, he's not alive.
Bro, he's not alive.
I gave him, like, a minute and 12 seconds, guys.
Yeah, you might have to dig out the VOD chat.
I forgot to give you the...
I forgot to, like, tell you what the Twitter handles were.
I just saw it on my end and I was like, okay, there they are.
Oh, I'm sorry.
We might have to pull a fifth one.
He hasn't awakened.
I'm gonna wait until, like, it hits 30 seconds.
How did he snooze?
We're going by so fucking fast, too.
I don't think he realized it was 5 codes.
Alright, he has 0 messages.
We're pulling a new winner.
Tugging Fortuna.
What a fucking name.
Congratulations!
You won the last code!
If you are allowed to claim it.
Alright, he gave...
Okay, I knew I forgot one thing for my mod.
In the past, I would just copy and paste what the handle was.
But then, like, I forgot to do that and I just said it out loud.
So, like, my mod has to look through the chat now to find the other handle.
But, if you did win and my mod has not written down your handle yet, feel free to add my mod, SilentCactus, so you can write down your handle.
Oh my god, but congratulations, everybody!
For winning the code!
Thank you, guys, for the fun times with Monster Hunter Wilds Launch.
I had a great time playing Monster Hunter Wilds.
And playing with my Dragoons and playing on launch day.
It was really, really fucking fun.
And, honestly, like, great experience.
Like, you guys, I don't know about doing more of a series for this.
I'm not sure yet.
But we'll see how I feel.
We'll see how I feel.
Because, like, I did have a really fun time.
I just don't know if I want to make it a series.
Because I do have Dynasty Warriors and stuff like that, too.
So, I don't know.
I really do want to finish Dynasty Warriors first before we get into another series.
But it was really fun.
I definitely want to do this as a member stream in the future, for sure.
But thank you guys.
I hope you guys had a great time watching.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.